avant d'en venir à l'examen des articles
du projet de loi je précise que
1499 amendements ah pardon je suis pas
sur le monde
la session extraordinaire débutera lundi
prochain par l'examen du projet de loi
pour le plein d'emploi ce texte est donc
à l'ordre du jour de notre commission
cette semaine je remercie monsieur le
ministre charolivier de venir nous
présenter ce texte à l'issue de son
examen par le Sénat en juillet dernier
comme de coutume cette audition tiendra
lieu de discussions générales
conformément aux décisions prises par le
bureau de la commission en début de
législature s'agissant d'un texte
important le temps de parole des
orateurs de groupe après le propos du
ministre et des rapporteurs sera de 5
minutes les autres interventions
demeureront limitées à deux minutes
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
merci madame la présidente Madame et
Monsieur les rapporteurs mesdames et
messieurs les députés permettez-moi
d'abord de vous dire le plaisir que je
vais vous retrouver le plaisir que j'ai
à vous féliciter madame la Présidente
pour votre élection et donc ceux à la
suite de Fadila catabi avec qui j'aurai
le plaisir et vous aussi dans notre
circonstances de continuer à travailler
dans les nouvelles responsabilités qui
sont les siennes je suis très heureux de
vous présenter le projet de loi
concernant le plus d'emploi qui
évidemment est un projet de loi qui
s'inscrit dans la droite ligne des
réformes que les gouvernements
successifs même depuis 2017 en faveur du
plein emploi et c'est à la fois un texte
qui s'inscrit dans cette droite ligne
mais aussi un texte qui représente un
jalon important en matière de politique
de l'emploi et un texte qui a déjà fait
l'objet d'une discussion parlementaire
puisque il a été adopté le 11 juillet
dernier au Sénat après plusieurs
évolutions au cours de la séance et des
débats
l'objectif est simple il est dans le
titre il s'agit d'atteindre le plein
emploi pour tous et c'est tout
l'ambition toute la priorité qui est
celle à la fois du gouvernement et du
ministère d'angélateur comme j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire lors de l'examen
au Sénat je pense qu'il est bon de
rappeler que quand le chômage nous
n'avons manifestement pas tout essayé
qu'il faut continuer à avancer à
travailler et alors qu'après des
décennies de chômage de masse notre taux
de chômage est aujourd'hui au plus bas
depuis 1982 que dans le même temps le
taux d'emploi est au plus haut depuis
que l'INSEE mesure c'est-à-dire 1975
tant pour la population générale que
pour l'activité des jeunes et des
seniors nous devons continuer continuer
nos efforts pour permettre l'accès à un
véritable plein emploi
nous avons mené plusieurs réformes
depuis 2017 d'abord pour faciliter les
jeunes l'accès des jeunes à l'emploi
avec la réforme de l'apprentissage avec
le contre engagement jeune ou encore la
réforme plus récente du lycée
professionnel nous avons aussi modernisé
rénover la
régime de l'assurance chômage en 2019
puis en 2022 et nous savons que un
chantier extrêmement important nous
attend sur la question de l'emploi des
seniors notamment dans le cadre des
discussions que nous avons confié aux
partenaires sociaux au titre de
l'article L1 du Code du travail
aujourd'hui avec ce texte nous vous
proposons de travailler sur trois volets
principalement et finalement de réformer
le service public de l'emploi notamment
l'accompagnement qu'il propose aux
personnes les plus éloignées de l'emploi
en question
c'est un projet de loi qui s'appuie à la
fois sur un constat et sur une
conviction le constat c'est que les
entreprises peinent à recruter alors que
le chômage reste important et que donc
notre service public de l'emploi peut
parfois manquer d'efficacité pour faire
se rencontrer l'offre et la demande du
travail tout converge pour le dire
malgré les efforts de l'ensemble des
personnels tant du service public de
l'emploi que des acteurs de l'emploi et
de l'insertion il y a une complexité une
atomisation une forme d'inatelligibilité
et de difficultés de coordination avec à
la clé des parcours qui sont des
parcours hachés qui nuisent à la
situation des plus fragiles sans
répondre aux besoins des entreprises en
matière de recrutement pour les
travailleurs en situation de handicap
particulièrement le parcours
d'orientation est encore plus complexe
très souvent impersonnelle et souvent
source de déception et même
d'incompréhension
la deuxième point deuxième sujet que je
souhaite aborder en propos liminaire
tiens à la conviction que personne est
une employable et que nous devons
permettre grâce à ces mesures l'accès au
marché du travail à tous et donc
d'inclure ceux qui sont les plus
éloignés de l'emploi de donner ou de
redonner un emploi au plus fragile cela
même qui pendant des décennies ont
parfois été relégué au second rang par
la fatalité du chômage de masse c'est
donc tout l'objectif de ce projet de loi
rénover le service public de l'emploi
mieux le coordonner et mieux accompagner
les personnes en recherche d'emploi
comme les entreprises qui souhaitent
recrutées avant de venir sur les
dispositions du texte je voudrais dire
un mot de la méthode d'élaboration de
celui-ci
en septembre 2022 j'ai confié une
mission de concertation et de
préfiguration à Thibault guili au
commissaire à l'emploi et l'engagement
des entreprises qui m'a rendu son
rapport le 17 avril dernier après 8 mois
de concertation le projet de loi que je
vous présente reprend l'essentiel des
principes relevés par la mission et
rendu je crois assez consensuel par la
concertation et c'est un travail très
important fondamental qui a effectué
Tibo Ghili pour préparer ce texte pour
préparer ce rapport avec de nombreuses
rencontres de l'ensemble des acteurs et
la possibilité d'avancer pour des
propositions de disposition législatives
parfois des textes réglementaires mais
aussi pour mettre à jour des bonnes
pratiques qui ne sont ni législatives ni
réglementaires mais qui peuvent
permettre d'améliorer l'accompagnement
des plus éloignés de l'emploi il y a un
deuxième axe du texte qui a fait l'objet
d'autres discussions c'est là que ce qui
concerne l'emploi des personnes en
situation de handicap et cet axe reprend
toutes les dispositions toutes les
annonces faites par le Président de la
République lors de la Conférence
nationale du handicap le 26 avril
dernier
les mesures pour l'emploi des personnes
en situation de handicap sont elles
aussi issues d'une large concertation
avec des groupes de travail propres à la
Conférence nationale du handicap et à
l'issue des mesures une vingtaine qui
ont fait l'objet d'un consensus devant
cette conférence nationale du handicap
et celle qui nécessite une traduction
législative sont donc dans le texte que
je présente devant vous enfin je l'ai
dit le texte a déjà été enrichi par le
Sénat sur plusieurs points sur lesquels
je reviendrai
il y a trois volets principaux sur
lesquels je souhaite m'arrêter un
instant pour détailler d'écrire les
dispositions du texte que je défends
devant vous le premier volet concerne
l'accompagnement des personnes les plus
éloignées de l'emploi avec aujourd'hui
certains constats qui sonnent comme
autant d'alerte ainsi 16% des
allocataires du RSA ils sont encore
inscrits plus de 10 ans après leur
première inscription et une étude de
2022 menée par la Cour des comptes a
montré que 42% des allocataires du RSA
sont inscrits de manière permanente ou
intermittente au RSA s'étend après leur
première inscription nous savons aussi
que 18% des allocataires ne sont suivis
par aucun organisme ni social ni
socioprofessionnel et ne connaissent du
RSA que la location sans qu'il y ait un
accompagnement et cette carence
d'accompagnement de 18% en moyenne
s'élève parfois plus de 30% en fonction
de la situation et de la capacité à agir
d'un certain nombre de départements il y
a une petite quinzaine de départements
dans lesquels nous sommes à 30% des
locataires qui n'en le qui n'ont aucun
organisme de référence
puis convaincu que nous ne sommes pas
kids de notre devoir solidarité par le
versement de quelques centaines d'euros
et que atténuer les symptômes de la
précarité n'en fera jamais disparaître
les causes et donc nous avons un travail
à faire pour renforcer l'accompagnement
et l'insertion par le travail dont on
besoin les plus fragiles et pas pour
entretenir cette situation de précarité
et c'est avec ce que nous voulons faire
avec ce projet de loi finalement tenir
pour de bon la promesse de solidarité
qui est celle du RSA avec une série de
mesures concrètes permettant par la
formation par l'insertion l'accès à
l'emploi à chaque fois que cela est
possible il y a donc des mesures
concrètes notamment le fait que
l'ensemble des personnes recherchent
d'emploi et notamment l'ensemble des
allocataires du RSA ou des jeunes en
recherche d'emploi accompagnés par les
missions locales soit inscrite auprès de
l'opérateur France travail c'est un
moyen essentiel pour garantir un
accompagnement à chacun et éviter les
ruptures de parcours nous savons que
parmi les allocataires du RSA certains
sont extrêmement isolés certains sont
aussi extrêmement fragilisés et ne sont
pas nécessairement en mesure de
retrouver un emploi immédiatement et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
prévu que ce soit toujours possible
évidemment la possibilité de bénéficier
uniquement si je puis dire d'un
accompagnement social qui permet d'aller
vers un accompagnement professionnel
lorsque la personne en aura retrouvé les
capacités la force et l'accompagne
nous avons aussi voulu pour les plus
isolés que le projet de loi puisse
prévoir dans son article 6 la
reconnaissance et la sécurisation des
acteurs en très grande majorité
associatif qui existe aujourd'hui et qui
font un formidable travail pour repérer
aller vers les personnes qui ne sont
plus suivies par les acteurs
traditionnels de l'insertion et de
l'emploi sont des acteurs qui existent
souvent associatifs qui nous font
reconnaître à intégrer au réseau des
acteurs pour l'insertion et Pôle emploi
ensuite nous souhaitons que le parcours
d'accompagnement soit formalisé dans le
cadre d'un contrat d'engagement qui soit
rénové et unifié pour plus de lisibilité
d'efficacité ce nouveau contrat
d'accompagnement sera un contrat
d'engagement proposé à tous les
demandeurs d'emploi quel que soit leur
situation il pourra détailler les
engagements réciproques de l'organisme
référent notamment les ateliers les
actions de formation de mise en
situation professionnelle de levée de
frein à l'emploi ainsi que les
engagements notamment d'acidité de
participation de la personne accompagnée
il s'agit évidemment pas de travail
gratuit ni de bénévolat obligatoire mais
bien d'activité d'insertion et de
formation pour permettre le retour à
l'emploi
ce contrat devra intégrer un plan
d'action qui précise des objectifs
d'insertion sociale et professionnelle
du demandeur d'emploi et il tiendra
compte évidemment la situation de la
personne en matière de mobilité de garde
d'enfants quand c'est nécessaire ou de
prise en charge médicale ou sanitaires
nous voulons que le diagnostic soit plus
complet et les expérimentations qui sont
menées montrent très souvent un
diagnostic à deux voies à la fois la
voix ou le regard des acteurs des
travailleurs sociaux du département de
la CAF pour le suivi social et le regard
des conseillers en insertion
professionnelle de Pôle Emploi sont
nécessaires pour avoir le meilleur
diagnostic possible et la meilleure
orientation possible il faudra aussi
travailler dans ce cadre là sur la levée
des freins en matière de logement je
l'ai dit le garde d'enfants de santé de
mobilité nous tiendrons compte et c'est
un des apports du Sénat que je souhaite
saluer de manière spécifique de la
situation des projets dents ou encore
des familles monoparentales qui n'ont
pas de solution aussi facile que bien
d'autres
nous voulons dans le cadre de ce contrat
d'engagement qui finalement que la
modernisation de celui prévu lors de la
création du RMI en 1988 nous voulons
faire en sorte que le régime de contrôle
et de sanction des allocataires du RSA
soient rénovée pour être plus progressif
mais aussi plus effectif aujourd'hui il
y a évidemment des procédures de
radiation du RSA qui sont menés par des
commissions
pluridisciplinaires au sein des conseils
départementaux qui en ont la compétence
nous souhaitons que soit créer un
nouveau un nouveau premier niveau de
sanction à la suspension qui permettra
de suspendre temporairement et donc plus
rapidement la location sans interrompre
l'accompagnement et si la personne
respecte ses engagements lui permettent
de bénéficier d'inversement rétroactif
des droits à défaut d'aller
malheureusement vers une procédure plus
contraignante qui rejoint celle qui
existe actuellement de radiation
enfin mais je l'ai dit nous voulons que
ce contrat puisse proposer un
accompagnement intensif et personnalisé
il nous semble que pour les personnes
les plus proches de l'emploi l'objectif
de 15 à 20h d'accompagnement par semaine
et le bon objectif avec des ateliers des
formations des solutions locales je
crois cependant que nous devons être
prudents sur ce point-là prudent parce
qu'il nous faut garantir la possibilité
pour l'ensemble des acteurs de l'emploi
de l'insertion de garantir 15 à 20h
parfaitement adapté aux personnes
partout sur le territoire prudent aussi
parce que je l'ai dit nous connaissons
des allocataires qui sont
particulièrement éloignés de l'emploi
depuis très longtemps et pour lesquels
une montée en charge progressive est
nécessaire si on souhaite réussir et
ainsi avoir une chance pour eux comme
pour nous de les accompagner vers
l'emploi donc travaillons pour faire en
sorte que cet objectif soit bien
objectif de droit commun mais que nous
puissions avancer aussi pour qu'il y ait
des solutions progressives et d'une
intensité qui soit la plus personnalisée
possible
cet accompagnement sera aussi renforcé
par la prise en compte des difficultés
de nature sociale je l'ai dit et devra
s'appuyer sur une offre de formation
renforcée c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous allons renouveler la
contractualisation plus réelle entre
l'État et les régions pour la formation
dans le cadre du plan d'investissement
dans les compétences avec un certain
nombre de priorités donnés à ces
formations à la fois pour qu'elle
concerne exploiter l'éligible les
publics les plus fragiles qu'elle
concerne aussi l'accompagnement des
recrutements tente dans les métiers qui
connaissent des tensions de recrutement
que dans les métiers de la transition et
tous ces métiers dont nous savons qu'ils
sont des gisements d'emploi extrêmement
importants dans les 10 ans qui viennent
nous devons éveiller nous devons aussi
veiller à ce que les publics soient les
publics concernés soient aussi larges
que possible c'est la raison pour
laquelle par exemple nous proposons que
les formations dispensées dans le cas du
plan d'investissement financé dans le
cadre du plan d'investissement dans les
compétences soit désormais accessible
jusqu'à des demandeurs d'emploi qui ont
un niveau diplôme inférieur à bac + 2
alors qu'aujourd'hui c'est inférieur au
bac et nous savons que malheureusement
de jeunes bacheliers après avoir connu
un problème d'orientation parfois un
échec en première année se trouve sans
solution et sont aujourd'hui privées de
l'accès aux formations financées dans le
cadre du pic parce que bachelier même
s'il rencontre ce problème d'accès à
l'emploi
il y a un second volet que je souhaite
présenter devant vous dans le cadre de
ce projet de loi qui concerne la
gouvernance du service public de
l'emploi et là c'est aussi un chantier
essentiel je l'ai dit les remontées de
terrain sont unanimes pour dire à la
fois des problématiques locales le
sentiment que les différents acteurs ne
se parlent pas assez entre eux et se
morcellement que je décrivais au début
de mon intervention le projet de loi
permet donc de construire une forme de
patrimoine commun au membre du réseau
des acteurs de l'insertion et de
l'emploi avec des méthodes des règles de
coordination des critères d'inscription
et d'orientation des référentiels
métiers qui seront à la fois mis en
commun et partager au sein du réseau
notamment grâce à un réseau de système à
la mise en réseau des systèmes
d'information pour véritablement
partager les données entre les
différents acteurs c'est la garantie
d'un suivi sans rupture c'est la
garantie d'un bon partage d'informations
et nous voulons faire évoluer le système
d'information de Pôle emploi en
plateforme plateforme France travail
pour faciliter le travail de chacun
c'est aussi plus d'informations pour les
collectivités et leurs élus avec des
données agrégées pour sur les parcours
sur les accompagnements sur la mise en
œuvre des les droits et des devoirs qui
seront ainsi régulièrement partagés avec
les collectivités associées à la
gouvernance de France travail nous
voulons que cette aspect soit fort et
nous voulons que la gouvernance soit
territorialisée possible c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous proposons que la
gouvernance puisse reposer sur un
copilotage entre l'État et les
collectivités locales à chaque échelon
territoriale pertinent nous voulons une
instance nationale avec l'État les
collectivités locales mais aussi les
partenaires sociaux bien sûr pour
déterminer les orientations stratégiques
et les modalités de pilotage au niveau
local nous souhaitons qu'il y ait un
comité régional qui sera qu'au président
de l'État dans la région et elle
représentant de la région un comité
départemental avec une courte présidence
partagée au titre notamment de
l'insertion entre le préfet de
départements et le président du conseil
départemental et pour les comités locaux
nous considérons que la meilleure façon
de procéder pour tenir compte des
spécificités des basses en emploi c'est
de permettre aux éléments de ces comités
de désigner parmi eux qui assure le
copilotage auprès de l'État dans
certains territoires ce sera les
intercommunalités ça s'imposera comme
une forme d'évidence dans d'autres ça
pourrait être ce pourrait être pardon un
élu régional ou un élu départemental en
fonction des caractéristiques du
territoire mais en la matière la
subsidarité nous paraît la meilleure des
clés et la meilleure façon de
fonctionner je tiens à souligner
concernant la gouvernance que nous ne
touchons pas aux compétences des
collectivités locales pas un article pas
une disposition ne revient sur la
répartition des compétences entre l'État
et les collectivités et pas un article
ne revient sur la répartition des
compétences entre les collectivités
elles-mêmes les régions gardent leur
prérogative pleine et entière sur la
formation comme les départements sur
l'insertion et les communes et les EPI
sur d'autres aspects l'action sociale de
proximité le logement ou encore les
transports
l'État des collectivités auront
conjointement la main pour orienter et
définir les orientations stratégiques de
l'action des opérateurs et des
partenaires du réseau et donc ça n'est
pas moins de compétences pour les
collectivités mais plus de visibilité et
une association avec une bonne et
libérative à la définition des
orientations auxquelles elles ne sont
pas associées aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
les collectivités locales ne participent
pas aux définitions à la définition des
orientations du service public de
l'emploi au niveau national pas plus
qu'elle ne participe à la définition des
orientations du service public national
d'état de l'emploi au niveau régional et
donc ce copilotage sur les orientations
stratégiques nous permettra de les
associer là où elles ne le sont pas
aujourd'hui et ainsi de pouvoir compter
sur l'implication puisque nous savons
que pour atteindre le plein emploi la
levée des freins l'accès à la formation
et l'insertion sont absolument
essentielles et sans l'implication des
collectivités ça ne peut pas être réussi
vous l'avez compris dans ce cadre là
nous nous souhaitons que Pôle emploi
devenu France travail prenne en charge
de nouvelles missions au service des
acteurs du réseau notamment sur les
systèmes d'information les référentiels
un certain nombre de débats ont eu lieu
au Sénat sur la question de la
dénomination et la rapporteur au Sénat
nous a notamment dit qu'elle considère
même si je ne partage pas son point de
vue qu'elle considère qu'il peut y avoir
une confusion entre appeler le réseau
des acteurs d'insertion de l'emploi
France travail et dénommé Pôle Emploi
France travail aussi je pense que les
débats que nous aurons que vous aurez en
commission qui nous aurons dans
l'hémicycle nous permettront d'avancer
sur ce point de marquer à la fois
l'importance du changement dans la
transformation de l'opérateur principal
mais aussi la clarté sur le fait que
cette opérateur n'a pas de pouvoir de
subordination sur l'ensemble des acteurs
du réseau au contraire ils travaillent
pour leur compte en mettant en oeuvre
les orientations définies dans le cadre
des comités de pilotage
de la même manière ou plutôt dans le
même esprit les missions locales ainsi
que Cap Emploi pour les personnes en
situation de handicap pourront si le
souhaitent et uniquement si le
souhaitent se dénommait et se saisir la
marque France travail dans leur nom mais
uniquement sur la base du volontariat et
d'ailleurs pour répondre à certaines
interrogations les missions locales les
structures d'insertion par l'activité
économique dont le financement est
assuré principalement par l'État
aujourd'hui seront toujours
conventionnés directement par l'État et
non pas avec l'opérateur certaines
missions locales nous ont dit leur
crainte que demain ce soit l'opérateur
France travail qui assure leur
financement ça n'est pas notre volonté
ça n'est pas ce que prévoit le texte les
missions locales comme les SIAE
resteront conventionnés directement avec
l'État puisque si nous les faisions
financer par l'opérateur nous créerons
un lien de subordination que nous ne
voulons pas mettre en place
le troisième chantier enfant sur lequel
je souhaite m'arrêter un instant
concerne donc la poursuite de
l'engagement pour l'emploi des personnes
en situation de handicap je l'ai dit
aussi celle-ci rencontre encore trop
difficultés pour accéder et retourner à
l'emploi et donc nous voulons aller plus
loin autour de trois axes clairs d'abord
nous souhaitons améliorer l'orientation
professionnelle des personnes en
situation de handicap en confiance cette
orientation au service public de
l'emploi
et ainsi même si cela peut paraître
surprenant que cela relève de la loi
nous supprimons l'orientation vers le
marché du travailleur dinaire par les
MDPH et nous faisons de l'orientation en
milieu ordinaire un droit universel
puisque pour nous chacun est présumé
pouvoir y travailler un signe service
public de l'emploi proposera un
accompagnement à toute personne en
situation de handicap et sans emploi qui
en expriment le souhait comme pour tous
les demandeurs d'emploi et nous
considérons qu'un demandeur d'emploi en
situation de handicap est d'abord un
demandeur d'emploi et c'est si
l'insertion en milieu ordinaire n'est
pas possible malgré les aménagements et
les adaptations qu'a leur France
travaille pourra proposer une
orientation au milieu adaptée qui sera
mise en oeuvre par les MDPH c'est une
inversion d'une forme de paradis en
faisant de l'orientation en 1000
ordinaire un droit et un droit commun
pour permettre la construction d'un
projet professionnel et en recours quand
c'est nécessaire à différents
environnements que ce soit les esats les
entreprises adaptées ou encore l'emploi
accompagné
nous souhaitons donc mettre un terme aux
orientations prononcées uniquement sur
la base d'un dossier administratif sans
tenir compte de la capacité et de la
volonté des personnes de travailler en
milieu ordinaire
par ailleurs c'est un point aussi
important travailler avec les acteurs du
monde du handicap la trajectoire de
développement de l'emploi accompagné est
conforté et son pilotage confiés au
ministère du travail permettra de
soutenir les personnes en situation de
handicap invisible le deuxième axe
concernant l'emploi des personnes en
situation de handicap concernent
l'amélioration de l'accès aux droits des
personnes concernées ainsi les personnes
reconnues handicapées au titre d'une
pension d'invalidité ou d'une rente
d'incapacité auront les mêmes droits
prévus dans le code du travail que les
personnes titulaires du RQTH sans passer
par la MDPH je prends un simple exemple
mais si vous êtes reconnu handicapé au
titre d'une pension d'invalidité par la
Sécurité Sociale et que vous vous
présentez dans une entreprise adaptée
celle-ci ne peut pas vous recruter si
vous n'avez pas demandé à bénéficier
d'une aire QTH demain en prévoyant que
les personnes reconnues handicapées au
titre d'une pension d'invalidité
bénéficie des mêmes droits l'accès à
l'entreprise adaptée sera de droit comme
pour les personnes ayant une RQTH sans
amené des procédures administratives
nouvelles et supplémentaires de la même
manière nous voulons faire progresser
les droits des personnes en situation de
handicap et faire évoluer notamment les
droits sociaux individuels et collectifs
de ce que de ce qui sont aujourd'hui
appelés des utilisateurs des actes ou
des usagers des actes nous voulons ainsi
aller vers une prise en charge de la
mutuelle du transport domicile-travail
accordé le droit de grève et le droit
syndical aux travailleurs des ESAT comme
c'est le cas pour les travailleurs en
milieu ordinaire ou dans d'autres
structures adaptées ça nécessite
évidemment une période de convergence et
ça nécessite aussi un travail avec le
secteur de l'emploi adapté pour tenir
compte de ces changements et ainsi
revoir progressivement leur modèle de
financement enfin nous voulons favoriser
l'engagement des employeurs que ce soit
les employeurs privés ou public pour les
accompagner dans le recrutement de
personnes en situation de handicap
c'est la raison pour laquelle le modèle
des Entreprises Adaptées travaillent
temporaires et des contrats duré
déterminée des tremplins jusqu'à leur
expérimentaux rentreront de manière
pérenne dans le code du travail nous
répondrons ainsi à une demande très
forte des acteurs de l'emploi des
personnes en situation de handicap
il y a un quatrième volet du projet de
loi qui concerne le service public de la
petite enfance c'est l'article 10 qui
est porté défendu par ma collègue lise
et solidarités et des familles qui aura
l'occasion de venir l'évoquer et en
débattre avec vous je n'entre pas dans
le détail de ces dispositions enfin il y
a un volet qui prévoit la transposition
des mesures du texte au territoire
d'outre-mer nous sommes convaincus que
les caractéristiques très particulières
du marché de l'emploi dans les
territoires d'outre-mer nécessite des
déclinaisons et une forme de
différenciation c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous renvoyons cette
transposition à des mesures d'ordre
réglementaires dans le texte pour
permettre justement ces différenciation
et un travail autour de ces sujets là
bien évidemment au-delà du texte que je
vous présente aujourd'hui ce projet de
loi devra mobiliser des moyens
financiers sur toute la durée de sa mise
en place pour être efficace nous avons
un objectif pour atteindre le plan
emploi il s'agit de permettre
d'accompagner la création par notre
économie de 700 000 emplois d'ici la fin
du quinquennat un million 700 000 ont
déjà été créés dans le premier
quinquennat et un peu plus de 200 000 au
cours des derniers mois c'est un
objectif atteignable qui demande un
investissement social important
notamment dans l'accompagnement en
matière d'insertion et de formation mais
c'est aussi un retour à l'emploi qui a
des Verts qui a des vertus pour les
finances publiques au-delà de la seule
question de l'emploi et de l'insertion
accompagner les personnes les plus
éloignées de l'emploi et moins coûteux
que le chômage de longue durée augmente
activité en retour augmente aussi les
moyens d’état de notre capacité à la
fois à produire mais aussi à garantir la
cohésion sociale
la raison pour laquelle des moyens
supplémentaires seront inscrits dès le
projet de bâtiments pour 2024 avec une
montée en charge progressive des moyens
accordés notamment à Pôle Emploi auteur
300 millions d'euros en 2024 de 500
millions 2025 de 750 en 2026 pour
atteindre un milliard d'euros en 207 ces
moyens seront financés à la fois par la
trajectoire de subvention versée par
l'État à Pôle emploi mais aussi par une
trajectoire de contribution de l'inédits
à Pôle Emploi contribution de l'inédith
rendu possible notamment par les
économies permise par les différentes
réforme de l'assurance chômage par la
baisse du chômage qui se traduit par une
trajectoire d'excédent suffisamment
marquée pour permettre à la fois se
financement mais aussi un des
endettement extrêmement important de
l'énédique sur la même personne la même
période par ailleurs le financement de
France travaille passera aussi par un
nouveau cadre de contractualisation
entre l'État et les départements en 2024
ce sont 170 millions d'euros qui seront
consacrés par l'État à cette
contractualisation pour financer la
montée en charge de l'offre de service
et de l'accompagnement rénover des
allocataires du RSA qui se déploient
actuellement dans 18 bassins
d'expérimentation
expérimentation qui a vocation assez
largée et donc c'est la raison de
laquelle la raison pour laquelle nous
irons vers plus de contractualisation en
lien avec l'ADF pour que nous puissions
avoir une expérimentation plus forte et
plus robuste et donc plus riche
d'enseignements à la fin de l'année 2024
je l'ai dit nous allons aussi investir
massivement dans la contractualisation
avec les régions sur le plan
d'investissement dans les compétences
enfin nous allons conforter notre
soutien notre soutien aux acteurs de
l'insertion par l'activité économique en
tenant le cap fixée par le Président de
la République en 2018 sur le plan
ambition et en reconnaissant le secteur
associatif dans le cadre du dispositif
prévu à l'article 6
je termine par un mot pour vous dire que
les sénateurs ont introduit beaucoup de
dispositions nouvelles dans le texte et
que nous en gardons l'essentiel il y a
notamment des dispositions extrêmement
intéressantes sur la prise en compte des
projets d'onde des représentants des
usagers sur l'amélioration des réponses
apportées aux besoins de recrutement des
entreprises notamment pour les personnes
en situation de handicap ou le lien avec
l'éducation nationale ou encore la
pérennisation de l'organisation de
l'emploi accompagné sous la forme de
plateforme départementale il y a
d'autres sujets qui n'ont pas trouvé la
mêmeanimité ou même consensus autour de
la question des cases amateurs la
disposition adoptée par le Sénat
appliquerait les 15 amateurs de manière
minimale à tous les allocataires j'ai
dit tout à l'heure notre souhait que ce
soit plus progressive pour tenir compte
de la situation de chacun et des
capacités de l'action publique il y a
quelques différences sur les questions
de gouvernance territoriale et nous
souhaitons que des dispositions puissent
être adoptées pour mieux garantir
l'équilibre de représentation des
différents niveaux de collectivité
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre pour
cette présentation très complète je vais
passer maintenant la parole au
rapporteur en commençant par Monsieur
Paul Christophe qui a un porteur sur le
Titre 1 et 2
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le projet
de loi qui appelle aujourd'hui notre
examen et la traduction de la volonté
politique portée par le gouvernement et
sa majorité d'atteindre le plein emploi
grâce à la transformation du service
public de l'emploi et à
l'intensification de l'accompagnement
des demandeurs d'emploi et des
bénéficiaires du revenu de solidactique
le RSA notons que cette ambition de
plein poids a été soulignée par
l'ensemble des auditions lors de notre
préliminaires ce projet doit trouve sa
source dans les travaux de préfiguration
conduit par le haut-commissaire à
l'emploi et l'engagement des entreprises
monsieur thibault-ghili et les
expérimentations actuellement en cours
sur nos territoires vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur ministre celui-ci s'inscrit
dans un contexte d'amélioration
significative du marché du travail dans
notre pays peut être fier non seulement
notre taux de chômage est historiquement
bas à 7,2%. mais en Suisse de cela la
part de Célie est aussi très élevée
parmi les emplois créés mais malgré ses
résultats très encourageants ont eu une
partie de nos concitoyens reste
durablement éloignés de l'emploi et donc
mécaniquement enfermé dans une situation
de très grande précarité
un constat dont personne ne peut bien
évidemment se satisfaire l'article
premier prévoit ainsi la transformation
de la nature même de la liste des
demandeurs d'emploi qui devient un outil
d'accompagnement de l'ensemble des
personnes sans emploi pour leur
insertion sociale et professionnelle il
définit en outre un nouveau cadre
d'orientation des demandeurs d'emploi
qui a été
utilement précisé par les sénateurs en
cohérence l'article de modifie le régime
des droits et devoirs des demandeurs
d'emploi à travers un contrat
d'engagement rénové jusqu'à lors les
contrats signés par les allocataires du
RSA ne formulent trop souvent aucune
action à visée d'emploi par conséquent 7
ans après l'entrée au RSA seul 11% des
bénéficiaires on retrouvait un emploi
durable alors que 60% d'entre eux sont
encore à locataire 5 ans après leur
première inscription pourtant nombreux
parmi eux sont en capacité de travailler
et le revendique c'est pourquoi nous
voulons que demain la locataire et son
référent puissent se fixer ensemble des
objectifs progressifs afin de lui
construire de nouvelles perspectives
professionnelles mais aussi de lever les
freins périphériques qu'il connaît que
ce soit en matière de santé de logement
ou de garde d'enfants par exemple la
question de la mise en oeuvre du plan
d'action sera un point important de nos
débats en effet au dispositions figurant
initialement dans le projet de loi les
sénateurs ont ajouté une obligation
d'activité d'au moins 15 heures par
semaine au-delà d'une impossibilité dans
les faits de mettre en place un tel
dispositif pour tous celui-ci risquerait
de faire taire les grandes difficultés
sociales et professionnelles rencontrées
par certains allocataires se remettre en
cause l'idée que ce contrat doit
replacer au cœur du dispositif des
exigences d'engagement d'assiduité et de
motivation nous proposerons d'aménager
la rédaction proposée par le Sénat tout
comme nous reviendrons sur la mesure
liant la radiation de la liste des
demandeurs d'emploi à celle des
bénéficiaires du RSA afin de ne jamais
perdre de vue notre objectif 2
poursuivre l'accompagnement des
demandeurs d'emploi les portes du
service public de l'emploi leur seront
toujours ouvertes
en cas d'échec de l'accompagnement se
traduisant par des manquements répétés
du demandeur d'emploi à ses obligations
rappelons qu'à un régime de sanctions
existe déjà et se traduit par une
suppression de la location et une
rupture de l'accompagnement c'est cette
logique que nous souhaitons faire
évoluer l'article 3 construit ainsi un
régime de sanctions plus progressif par
la création d'une censure sanction dite
de suspension remobilisation par
celle-ci le bénéficiaire verra son
allocation suspendue temporairement et
si la personne reprend son parcours et
les devoirs qui sont liés ces droits
seront restaurés et ses allocations lui
seront restituées j'en viens à présent
au titre 2 du projet de loi qui
constitue la réforme du service public
de l'emploi contrairement à ceux qui
affirme un grand nombre d'amendements
déposés les acteurs auditionnés ont tous
encouragé l'approche territoriale des
politiques de l'emploi et de l'insertion
opéré par le texte aussi l'article 4
crée en effet un réseau national
réunissant l'ensemble des acteurs de
l'emploi de la formation et de
l'insertion afin de définir un nouveau
cadre pour l'exercice de leurs
compétences et ce dans le respect de la
libre administration des collectivités
territoriales consacrées rappelons-le
par l'article 72 de la Constitution il
est vrai que la notion de Chartres
d'engagement a pu sembler coercitive
nous lui préférons par voie d'amendement
celle de charte de coopération dont la
signature par les collectivités locales
et leur groupement ne conditionnera pas
la coprésence des comités territoriaux
du réseau l'ensemble de ces acteurs
partageront un patrimoine commun vous
l'avez dit monsieur le ministre en
particulier numérique et méthodologique
fournies par l'opérateur France travail
dont nous vous proposerons de rétablir
la nouvelle domination en particulier à
l'article 5 qui définissent l'émission
si l'article 6 vise à mieux repérer les
personnes les plus éloignées de l'emploi
grâce à de nouveaux organismes associés
au réseau l'article 7 vise pour sa part
à développer en lien avec les régions
une offre nationale complémentaire de
formation à distance et à élargir
l'accès à la préparation opérationnelle
à l'emploi individuel
nous aurons l'occasion de débattre
mesures par mesure du bien fondé de
cette réforme ambitieuse mais je suis
convaincu qu'elle nous permettra
d'atteindre notre objectif à tous celui
d'accompagner au mieux l'insertion
sociale et professionnelle de nos
concitoyens et ainsi de les aider à
sortir de la pauvreté je laisse
désormais la parole à ma Cora porter
Madame Christine ledabour qui évoquera
avec nous les titres 3 et 4 du projet de
loi je vous remercie
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues il me revient à
présent de vous présenter les articles
des titres 3 et 4 du projet loi les
articles du titre 3 rassemblent un
certain nombre de dispositions qui
tendent à favoriser l'accès à l'emploi
et le maintien en emploi des personnes
en situation de handicap elle
s'inscrivent dans le prolongement des
réformes conduites sous la précédente
législature de la refond du régime de
l'obligation d'emploi des travailleurs
handicapés au programme cap vers
l'entreprise inclusive 2018-2022 du
rapprochement des réseaux de Pôle emploi
et de Cap emploi au plan de
transformation des esats pour ne citer
qu'elle ces réformes ont eu des effets
positifs il est bon de rappeler que le
taux de chômage des personnes en
situation handicap est passé de 19% à
13% entre 2017 et 2022 il est également
satisfaisant de constater que le taux
d'emploi direct des bénéficiaires de
l'eau ETH évolue positivement depuis
l'entrée en vigueur de la loi du 5
septembre 2018 pour la liberté de
choisir son avenir professionnel tout
cela est détaillé dans le rapport qui
vous a été transmis ces résultats sont
évidemment encourageants mais ils ne
sont pas suffisants dans les marges de
progrès demeurent importantes il y a
donc lieu que le Parlement légifère pour
améliorer la situation de ce public dans
le respect des orientations dégagées par
la mission de préfiguration de France
travail et des engagements formulés par
la Conférence nationale du handicap qui
s'est tenu le 26 avril dernier avec ce
texte la majorité présidentielle s'y
emploi l'article 8 enrichit la
législation sur plusieurs points il est
temps à l'ensemble des bénéficiaires de
l'obligation d'emploi des travailleurs
handicapés l'application des dispositifs
ouverts au seul travailleur reconnu
handicapés par la commission des droits
et de l'autonomie des personnes
handicapées c'est des APH ainsi de la
disponible de la possibilité pardon de
bénéficier du dispositif d'emploi
accompagné dont la gestion est transféré
à l'état ou d'être recrutés par une
entreprise adaptée par exemple il
supprime le principe de l'orientation de
ces travailleurs en milieu ordinaire de
sorte qu'elles deviennent l'orientation
de droit commun ouverte à tous sans
validation préalable au fin de faciliter
leur accès au marché du travail il
pérennise les dispositifs expérimentaux
relatifs au CD des tremplins et aux
Entreprises Adaptées de travail
temporaire qui génère de bons résultats
ce dont les acteurs du secteur se sont
unanimement félicités l'article 8 bisa
introduit à l'initiative du gouvernement
le recensement dans un système
d'information nationale des aménagements
ayant bénéficié à chaque personne en
situation de handicap dans le cadre de
la scolarité d'une formation ou d'un
emploi traduction législative d'une
annonce faite lors de la dernière
conférence nationale du handicap ce
nouveau service bâtissait baptisé sac à
dos numérique devra permettre une mise
en œuvre d'aménagement plus fluide et
plus rapide à toutes les étapes de la
carrière l'article 8 bisb introduit à
l'initiative du gouvernement là encore
inscrit dans la loi la règle selon
laquelle la portabilité des équipements
contribuant à l'adaptation du poste de
travail des travailleurs handicapés
pourra être prévu par convention entre
deux entreprises à l'occasion d'un
changement d'employeur le risque d'une
rupture dans les parcours professionnels
sera en conséquence mieux prévenu
l'article 8 bis introduit par la
commission des affaires sociales du
Sénat ouvrent la voie à la mise à
disposition d'une entreprise
utilisatrice d'un salarié temporaire au
motif qu'il bénéficie de l'obligation
d'emploi des travailleurs handicapés ce
faisant il confère un caractère pérenne
au dispositif expérimental créé par la
loi du 5 septembre 2018
l'article 9 traduit lui aussi plusieurs
annonces faites lors de la Conférence
nationale du handicap confie au service
public de l'emploi le soin d'accompagner
tous les demandeurs d'emploi y compris
ceux en situation de handicap faire
converger les droits individuels et
collectifs des travailleurs accueillis
en ESAT vers ceux que le code du travail
garantit aux salariés et enfin sécuriser
les parcours professionnels de ces
travailleurs
le Sénat a apporté quelques
modifications aux articles du titre 3
qui pour l'essentiel ne soulève pas de
difficultés je présenterai toutefois un
amendement pour supprimer le dispositif
ouvrant la voie à une modulation à la
baisse du montant de la contribution
versée par l'employeur pour s'acquitter
de l'obligation d'emploi des
travailleurs handicapés qui
résulteraient de l'effort consenti en
matière de maintien dans l'emploi ou de
recrutement direct des bénéficiaires de
l'obligation d'emploi notamment ceux qui
sont lourdement handicapés j'en viens
pour terminer à l'article 10 unique
article du titre 4 qui modifie
l'architecture de la gouvernance de la
politique d'accueil du jeune enfance
selon une double approche un clarifié
les rôles et les missions des acteurs au
plan national et local et instaurer de
nouveaux leviers d'actions et rénover
les leviers existants profitent ces
acteurs
les mesures qu'ils portent s'inscrivent
dans la perspective de la création du
service public de la petite enfance qui
suppose d'autres évolutions telles
l'augmentation du nombre de places de
crèches chacun sait que le gouvernement
a fait des annonces dans ce domaine cet
article a toute sa place dans le projet
de loi l'insuffisance quantitative de
l'offre d'accueil d'enfants de moins de
3 ans et plus généralement
l'inadaptation de cette offre au besoin
des familles à l'échelle du pays empêche
de nombreux parents d'accéder au marché
du travail ou de poursuivre leur
activité un phénomène qui pénalise très
majoritairement les femmes il est donc
impératif de lever ce frein connexe à
l'emploi permettez-moi d'évoquer
brièvement quelques unes des avancées
contenues dans l'article il fait des
communes qui interviennent déjà
largement dans le champ de la petite
enfance les autorités les autorités
organisatrices de la politique d'accueil
du jeune enfant tout en ajustant le
périmètre de leur obligation au regard
du nombre de leurs habitants il crée un
mécanisme de régulation de l'offre
d'accueil au plan local il améliore la
prise en compte avez besoin du secteur
dans les politiques de formation afin de
lutter contre la pénurie des
professionnels il facilite
l'implantation des structures d'accueil
sur le territoire vous le savez
l'article 10 a été substantiellement
modifié par les sénateurs ces derniers
ont en effet supprimé les dispositions
relatives à l'établissement d'une
stratégie nationale de l'accueil du
jeune enfant ainsi que les dispositions
relatives au contrôle du respect par les
communes de leur nouvelle obligations
ils ont aussi décidé que l'élaboration
du schéma pluriannuel de maintien et de
développement de l'offre d'accueil du
jeune enfant ne serait imposé qu'aux
communes de plus de 10 000 habitants
faisant perdre dispositif une par
significative de sa portée ils ont
repoussé d'un an l'entrée en vigueur des
dispositions touchant à la mise en
oeuvre des nouvelles compétences
reconnues aux communes ils ont enfin
autorisé le principe du transfert aux
intercommunalités de tout ou partie des
compétences attachées à la qualité
d'autorité organisatrice de l'accueil du
jeune enfant une solution préférée à
celle du transport du transfert en bloc
initial initialement retenu
avec la majorité je vous proposerai de
revenir sur certaines de ces évolutions
et d'apporter au texte quelques
modifications complémentaires pour en
faire le support d'une réforme cohérente
utile et ambitieuse de la gouvernance de
la politique du jeune enfant je vous
remercie
merci madame le rapporteur nous passons
maintenant aux orateurs de groupe et ce
partageons le temps dédié au groupe
Renaissance madame Michel perron et
Madame Nicole du brésira
merci madame la Présidente cherche
Charlotte que je souhaite d'abord saluer
félicité pour son élection monsieur le
ministre monsieur et madame les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues après
une première étape à travers la loi
visant à améliorer le fonctionnement du
marché du travail promulgué en 2022 nous
poursuivons doréforme afin d'atteindre
l'objectif de plein emploi que nous nous
sommes fixés c'est ainsi que ce projet
de loi porte cette ambition un emploi
pour tous un accompagnement
socioprofessionnel renforcé pour les
personnes qui en ont le plus besoin une
transformation du service public de
l'emploi et de l'insertion ce projet de
loi permet de poser le cadre afin de
permettre une amélioration substantielle
de l'offre de service proposée aux
personnes en recherche d'emploi mais
également aux entreprises grâce à une
meilleure coopération des acteurs à
travers le rassemblement des acteurs du
SPEI au sein du réseau France travail en
contrepartie de cette amélioration de
l'offre de service le bénéficiaire devra
s'engager à suivre un parcours
d'insertion sinon son allocation pour
être suspendue ou supprimer grâce à ce
texte nous renforçons l'accompagnement
des demandeurs d'emploi et des
bénéficiaires du RSA dans le cadre d'un
unique contrat d'engagement et d'une
inscription automatique comme demandeur
d'emploi pour tous le Sénat en première
lecture à apporter des modifications
donc pour certaines nous porterons des
propositions de précision ou de
nouvelles rédactions concernant les
titres 1 et 2 les auditions pointées la
difficulté de réalisation des 15 20
heures d'activités pour les
bénéficiaires du RSA à titre d'exemple
une femme isolée avec des enfants en bas
âge ne pourra effectuer par exemple 15
heures de formation au démarrage de son
parcours avant que des solutions
relatives à la garde de ses enfants
soient identifiés ainsi notre groupe
présentera un amendement de précision
afin d'y ajouter la prise en compte de
la réalité des besoins et de la
situation particulière des personnes
nous proposerons rétablir le changement
de dénomination de Pôle emploi en le
transformant en opérateur France travail
et de supprimer l'articulation entre les
listes de demandeurs d'emploi et de
bénéfaire du et de B et de bénéficier du
RSA en effet la radiation d'une liste
entraînée automatiquement la radiation
dans l'autre liste comme je l'ai dit ce
projet de loi pose un cadre fondateur et
une avancée conséquente de plus vers le
plein emploi monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous nous dresser un bilan de
compte du contrat d'engagement jeune
dont s'inspire l'accompagnement renforcé
prévu par ce texte merci
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre mesdames et messieurs au
printemps dernier a eu lieu la
conférence nationale du handicap à la
suite de laquelle des concertations ont
eu lieu avec les différents ministères
concernés ces travaux ont permis de
proposer 17 mesures notamment centrées
sur la reconnaissance du handicap
l'accès à la formation la compagnement
des personnes en situation de handicap
en recherche d'emploi ce projet de loi
réaffirme l'orientation de toute
personne dans un circuit plus lisible
simplifié plus adapté à ses besoins
notamment pour les personnes en
situation de handicap en 2018 et 2020
proposition a été faite de rapprocher
Pôle emploi et Cap Emploi pour mieux
appréhender les besoins et accompagner
la personne handicapée et accompagner
aussi l'entreprise qu'il accueille ce
dispositif installé ne fonctionne pas de
la même façon selon les territoires
pouvez-vous nous dire quels sont les
bénéfices de ce travail commun au moment
où ces organismes sont positionnés au
sein du réseau France travail et doivent
travailler en complémentarité pour que
ce soit le travail qui s'adapte à la
personne et non plus la personne à
l'emploi je vous remercie
merci beaucoup
monsieur Jocelyn decigny pour le
rassemblement national
merci madame le Président Monsieur le
Ministre quel dommage et surtout quelle
occasion manquer le principe d'un
guichet unique en matière de retour à
l'emploi était pertinent et je dirais
même qu'il était une nécessité attendu
par toute la profession sous réserve
bien sûr qu'il soit axé sur la véritable
priorité le principe de proximité il
doit être déployé jusqu'au cœur des
territoires au plus près des citoyens au
prix actuel du carburant il ne peut se
trouver à plus de 20 km en voiture du
domicile des demandeurs d'emploi ce
guichet unique doit être tenu par des
personnes par des êtres humains pas en
visioconférence ou pire encore par le
biais d'un énième algorithme un suivi de
parcours ne peut avoir lieu à distance
il ne doit pas non plus y avoir
d'exclusion numérique l'électronisme est
une réalité de nombreux cas en province
et il ne faut donc pas qu'il y ait de
nécessité à peu céder un ordinateur pour
pouvoir faire sa recherche d'emploi ou
pour pouvoir être en contact avec son
son opérateur chez Pôle Emploi un point
du texte amélioré serait la clé de
succès de cette réforme à notre sens
tient à l'amélioration de la formation
dispensée en France il y a un déficit
majeur en compétences les Français ne
sont pas formés selon les besoins du
marché la corrélation des compétences
des personnes aux besoins des
entreprises est en souffrance elle doit
correspondre de manière plus ajustée au
nécessité immédiate des entreprises et
au projet industriels qu'on décide pour
la France la industrialisation
l'intelligence artificielle et le
numérique la science des données la
cybercriminalité le nucléaire
l'automobile la construction ou encore
l'économie du grand âge autre point à
renforcer les contrôles du service
national de la lutte contre les contre
la fraude à ses enjeux ils doivent être
plus robustes dès à présent la fraude
sociale est insupportable pour nous
concitoyens il faut faire un effort sur
ce point enfin dans ce texte on révèle
on relève trois difficultés majeures la
multitude et l'incompatibilité des
acteurs de la gouvernance stratégique
qui exclut par ailleurs le principal à
savoir Pôle Emploi condamne votre projet
un immobilisme certain qui le rendra de
fait inefficace l'obligation d'activité
hebdomadaire apporte aussi de la
confusion à ce texte et ouvre une porte
au dévoiement du dispositif de retour à
l'emploi enfin le coût de cette réforme
ce ministre vous avez évoqué deux
virgule 7 milliards d'euros avec un
déficit public abyssal comment
comptez-vous financer ce projet en bref
vous mettez en place un dispositif de
gouvernance voué à l'immobilisme sans
aucune des mesures courageuses qui font
défaut à son fonctionnement pire encore
vous remplacer la démoniation France
travail à Pôle Emploi
inutile et qui va rendre la mise en
place plus floue et qui va obliger à
changer toutes les enseignes et tous les
logos de France avez-vous monsieur le
ministre
réfléchi au coup que cela va représenter
pour le contribuable et est-ce donc là
votre seul priorité pour les Français je
vous remercie
merci Madame Simonet pour la France
insoumise
madame la Présidente chers collègues
monsieur le ministre ce texte est en
fait la suite directe de la réforme des
retraites imposée par 49.3 contre la vie
de 93% des actifs car en volant deux ans
de vie au peuple vous allez créer des
dizaines de milliers de seniors privés
d'emplois qui se retrouveront au RSA et
parce que travailler en étant âgé
augmente les risques autant qu'ils se
retrouveront en situation de handicap
dans la capacité de travail et vous avez
un problème tout cela va coûter un
pognon dingue votre solution le travail
gratuit ou sous-payé à 7 euros de
l'heure et inscrire de force les
allocataires du RSA les jeunes des
missions locales les personnes en
situation de handicap comme demandeur
d'emploi il est forcé à 15 heures
d'activité par semaine vous imposez aux
allocataires une alternative sordide
accepter n'importe quel boulot même
sous-payés au gré des exigences du
moment du patronat ou être radié celles
et ceux qui vont payer le prix mais
chers collègues ce sont les enfants qui
n'auront plus à manger puisque le RSA
insuffisant de leurs parents pourraient
être renier voir suspendu ce les mers
isolés en France 96% des allocataires du
RSA majoré sont des femmes et plus d'une
sur deux à plus d'un enfant à charge et
à qui cette réforme va-t-elle profiter
aux organismes privés de placement que
votre ami Marc ferrachi connaît très
bien en criant indirect qui vont voir
leur poids accru puisque vous augmentez
les missions publiques tout de suite je
vous invite
parce que pas d'attaque personnelle
gratuite comme vous le faites pas digne
des débats qu'on a ici
ça coûte cher au contribuable de notre
côté nous portons une logique inverse
celle de lutter réellement contre les
destructions d'emplois d'en créer avec
la planification écologique et le
développement des services publics celle
d'une garantie d'emploi avec l'État
employeur en dehors en dernier ressort
des territoires zéro chômeurs de longue
durée dont vous avez l'as décidé cet été
de baisser fortement les moyens c'est
l'enfant d'un service public de l'emploi
qui accompagne les gens au lieu de les
fliquer et d'un droit inconditionnel à
une garantie dignité supérieure au seuil
de pauvreté le préambule de la
Constitution fonde un droit à l'aide
sociale au profit des personnes sans
retour de notre Constitution vous ne
gardez que les rouages qui vous
permettent de gouverner contre le peuple
se sont à l'inverse les principes
républicains de liberté d'égalité de
fraternité qu'il nous faut faire vivre
monsieur juvain pour les républicains
vous venez de dire que il fallait
s'intéresser au fond et vous avez raison
il faut s'intéresser au fond le fond
d'abord c'est que les chiffres du
chômage en France ne sont pas bons ils
ne sont pas bons 23e pays sur 27 donc il
faut cesser de s'auto gratuituler en
disant que tout va bien 23ème sur 25 et
en même temps 4 ou 5 millions de
chômeurs je dis quatre ou cinq parce que
la comptabilité est un mystère
administratif et pas une seule
entreprise pas une seule municipalité
par une seule maison de retraite par un
seul hôpital qui ne cherche quelqu'un il
est là le vrai sujet alors nous nous
partageons les préoccupations qui ont
été
donnés par le ministre effectivement la
question du plein en bois du plein
emploi est un objectif absolument
capital et donc je pourrais vous dire
que je suis d'accord avec le titre
du texte la question du texte du titre
c'est son objectif principal faire que
toute personne en recherche d'emploi
soit inscrit auprès de Pôle Emploi nous
partageons cette préoccupation c'est une
bonne mesure de la défendrons et nous la
soutiendrons toutefois force est de
constater qu'il y a encore des sujets
qui nous inquiète d'abord le premier
sujet c'est celui d'une sorte de
recentralisation un peu larvée qu'on
retrouve un peu partout le texte du
Sénat améliorer les choses un très
clairement et c'est une bonne chose
j'espère que on va pas retrait tricoter
le texte du Sénat mais quand je reprends
l'article 10 madame Le Nabour vous nous
expliquez c'est formidable on va
officiellement dire que les communes
sont en charge des crèches la petite
enfance on savait d'ailleurs moi comme
plusieurs d'entre vous j'ai été maire
ici je sais pas si vous l'avez été mais
les communes font ça depuis longtemps
sauf que d'un côté on dit aux communes
vous allez exercer ce droit et on leur
crée un schéma pluriannuel de maintien
et de développement de l'accueil des
jeunes enfants validé par une instance
département mental merci pour les Verts
et repris en main par l'État ouvrez les
guillemets en cas de manquement c'est
une décentralisation comment dirais-je
surveiller liberté surveillée où on
donne d'un côté au maire des pouvoirs
mais surtout en surveille qui n'en fasse
pas usage trop exagéré de l'autre et
c'est ça qui nous inquiète c'est cette
absence de confiance en l'occurrence en
cette petite 4 article 10
envers les collectivités territoriales
moi je crois qu'on aurait tout intérêt à
travailler avec les collectivités
territoriales parce que quand les
collectivités territoriales travaillent
elles utilisent l'argent public
probablement plus efficacement que
l'État central et le service rendu est
probablement moins coûteux
deuxième préoccupation c'est
l'obligation des 15 heures d'activité
hebdomadaires pour l'ensemble des
allocataires du RSA vous le savez nous
portons cette proposition de longue date
et nous soutenons fermement son
inscription dans la loi bien sûr nous
savons que nous sommes pas tous égaux
devant la reprise d'activité et encore
moins devant l'emploi certains sont plus
éloignés que d'autres et nos débats
devront permettre ça a été dit par
quelques collègues ici de trouver une
traduction législative d'aménagement à
ce dispositif je pense en particulier
aux personnes en situation de handicap
aux parents isolés sans mode de garde
mais le principe des 15 heures doit être
inscrite dans la loi parce que si vous
ne l'inscrivez pas en fait il sera
détourné comme il est détourné
aujourd'hui
troisième point qui a été peu évoqué
c'est la question du contrôle alors j'ai
entendu que Red et contrôle mais comment
ça va fonctionner je dirais nous serons
particulièrement attentifs pendant ces
débats aux garanties apportées sur la
réalisation de contrôle suffisant pour
l'application effective donc de ces 15
heures d'activité enfin nous souhaitons
alerter sur le coût financier de la
réforme estimé entre deux et trois
milliards d'euros sur trois ans avec un
petit regret toutefois c'est qu'il y a
une étude d'impact très intéressante
sauf que dans l'étude d'impact il y a
pas un seul chiffre pas un seul donc
c'est un impact non financier ça n'a pas
de
sociologique philosophique
bureaucratique mais ce n'est pas un
impact financier or on voit bien qu'on
est obligé de se poser quand même des
questions de qui paye avec quoi
le rapport de travail du
haut-commissaire apporte quelques
quelques précisions intéressantes et ça
serait l'unique qui probablement se
serait ponctionné malgré le fait que
l'une des Dick a 42 milliards d'euros de
dettes en 2025 et ça c'est vrai que
c'est un sujet qui ne peut pas être
évacué enfin mes collègues évoqué la
question de la formation c'est
fondamental pourquoi les entreprises
cherchent-elles alors qu'il y a des
chômeurs c'est que probablement notre
système de formation est inadapté et
c'est un sujet qui malheureusement est
absent même si on comprend que dans une
telle loi on ne peut pas y mettre tout
mais c'est un sujet important voilà
Monsieur le Ministre madame la
Présidente sur l'ensemble de ces sujets
le groupe les républicains sans remettre
au débat et restera vigilant aux
solutions qui seront proposées
merci merci Madame Anne Bergans pour le
groupe modem et indépendant
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues en préambule de
mon intervention je souhaite évoquer la
notion du travail et de son sens
parallèlement à l'objectif d'atteindre
du plénon poids auquel nous ne pouvons
que souscrire ce texte
ouvre un débat idéologique sur la
question du travail et de sa place dans
notre société nous croyons très
profondément au groupe démocrate que le
travail est une source d'émancipation
d'inclusion d'insertion ou de
réinsertion le travail c'est aussi une
réalité économique permettant d'oeuvrer
à la réduction de la pauvreté et
d'accompagner la dynamique économique de
notre pays c'est sur ces certitudes que
notre majorité a œuvré depuis 2017 cela
amené à des résultats indéniables 1,7
millions d'emplois ont été créés et nous
n'avons pas vu un taux de chômage aussi
bas depuis plus de 40 ans si nous
pouvons nous féliciter de cette
progression il reste encore de nombreux
défis à relever ces défis ce sont les 3
millions de de catégorie ce sont les 1,4
millions de jeunes inactifs appelés
aussi les femmesites à savoir sans
diplôme sans emploi et non inscrit dans
une formation enfin ce sont près de 2
millions de foyers au RSA en progression
de 46% depuis 10 ans dans plus de la
majorité le perçoit depuis plus de 2 ans
et plus d'un tiers depuis plus de 5 ans
permettez-moi de rappeler deux constats
le premier repos sur la dichotomie entre
le nombre de chômeurs de bénéficiaires
du RSA qui peine à revenir vers l'emploi
et de l'autre des entreprises qui
peinent à recruter rappelons ces
chiffres et pharaons deux tiers des PME
disent rencontrer des difficultés de
recrutement et 60% des entreprises
industrielles déclarent avoir renoncé à
augmenter leur activité faute de
candidats le second est que notre
système repose sur un grand nombre
d'acteurs travaillant en silo et sans
coordination ou pas assez en tout cas
cela induit des trous dans la raquette
des doublons et trop souvent des
ruptures de parcours ce n'est pas
satisfaisant
en réponse à ces défis le gouvernement a
présenté ce projet de loi après
plusieurs mois de concertation et
d'échanges avec les différents acteurs
du monde de l'insertion et de l'emploi
des échanges qui se sont poursuivis dans
le cadre des auditions menées au
Parlement et je tiens ici à saluer le
travail et le sérieux de nos deux
rapporteurs et collègues Madame
Christine Namour et Monsieur Paul
Christophe
ce projet est porteur de trois grands
objectifs le premier et l'amélioration
de la gouvernance du service public de
l'emploi autour de la création du réseau
France travail ce PJL pose un cadre de
coopération en faisant le parti du
dialogue de la coordination avec une
mise en œuvre progressive dans laquelle
la confiance au territoire aux acteurs
et aux demandeurs d'emploi et primordial
le deuxième objectif porte sur
l'amélioration de l'accompagnement des
demandeurs d'emploi via une meilleure
organisation pour repérer mobiliser et
accompagner les personnes les plus
employées de l'emploi en lien conscient
constant avec les entreprises et leurs
besoins cet objectif mis sur
l'accompagnement au plus vite sur un
accompagnement plus adéquat plus humain
plus intensif quand il peut l'être et
par étape pour d'autres situations
l'accompagnement est au cœur de ce PGM
c'est un énorme investissement mais qui
produira des résultats car on le sait ça
fonctionne la formation est un autre
enjeu majeur pour la réussite de notre
ambition dès lors que les comp sont
souvent un frein vers le retour à
l'emploi enfin le troisième objectif
consiste à apporter des mesures d'équité
indispensable et attendue pour certains
publics nous nous félicitons ici de la
poursuite de l'engagement pour l'emploi
à faveur des personnes handicapées dans
le parcours d'orientation et trop
souvent source de complexité nous
saluons également le fait que le psgl
évoque la question de la garde d'enfants
qui demeure trop souvent pour les femmes
l'un des principaux blocages à l'accès à
l'emploi près d'un tiers des BRSA sont
des femmes familles monoparentales
rappelons-le vous l'aurez compris chers
collègues notre objectif est donc de
mieux coordonner les acteurs du service
public de l'emploi d'améliorer
l'accompagnement des demandeurs d'emploi
et des entreprises cela au service des
demandeurs d'emploi eux-mêmes des
mesures censées soutenues par une vision
à laquelle nous démocrate adhérons et
que nous soutenons totalement je vous
remercie
merci Monsieur Delaporte pour le groupe
socialiste et à parenté
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame rapporteur monsieur le
reporter le projet de loi que nous
examinons aujourd'hui et décidément mal
nommé pour le plein emploi plein et je
cite le Larousse est un adjectif du
latin plénus qui est fait dans un
matériau qui ne comporte pas de vide or
l'aire du vide qui nous traverse
maintenant depuis six ans s'illustre
parfaitement par la tentative sans cesse
renouvelée de déstabilisation de notre
modèle social encore une fois vous allez
y mettre un coup de regriffe participant
à la stigmatisation des plus pauvres en
voulant finalement les rendre
responsables de leur nom ou leur mal
insertion vous invisibilisez ici le
premier responsable un état qui
aujourd'hui échoue et nous y reviendrons
dans la discussion à offrir un
accompagnement c'était pourtant la
promesse du RMI portée par les
socialistes et Michel Rocard un revenu
de subsistance et un accompagnement à la
hauteur avec comme boussole le refus de
la stigmatisation et au contraire au
bout du chemin la dignité retrouvée car
et contrairement à ce qu'a pu dire un
ancien ministre de l'Intérieur
Renaissance la location ça n'est pas la
réponse des lâches votre projet de
stigmatisation de mise sous contrôle des
locataires et donc d'abord vite
d'humanité le vide c'est également celui
de lequel vous projetez les Français
dans la continuité de vos travaux de SAP
du modèle social après avoir amputé
l'assurance chômage des travailleurs
tout en basculant les chômeurs en fin de
droit vers le RSA après avoir volé deux
ans de vie aux françaises et aux
Français par votre injuste réforme des
retraites qui va maintenir des centaines
de milliers de seniors sans emploi plus
longtemps au RSA nous vous retrouvons
aujourd'hui pour une réforme du RSA qui
va infiner se traduire par l'exclusion
de la location de ces chômeurs ou de ces
seniors sans emploi pour également vous
opposer que les organisations syndicales
sont une aliment contre ce texte tout
comme les associations qui œuvrent
contre la précarité tout comme les
personnes qui accompagnent les
allocataires du RSA tout comme les
collectivités locales les missions
locales les agents du service public de
l'emploi bref le vide au delà du projet
de l'absence d'écoute qui vous
caractérise c'est aussi invite
d'arguments de fondements scientifique
ou issus de l'expérience comment
Monsieur le Ministre pérennisé dans la
loi une expérimentation qui n'est pas
terminée et même pas commencé dans la
plupart des 18 départements
préfigurateurs monsieur le ministre nous
avons demandé à plusieurs reprises par
ailleurs des éléments sur le nombre de
sanctions leurs effets sociaux et vous
nous avez jamais répondu comment peut-on
légiférer ainsi plus largement les
députés socialistes et je pense
l'ensemble de mes collègues de la nups
vous invite à dire la documentation
scientifique et internationale qui
constate que le renforcement des
sanctions d'allocataires n'a défait sur
la réinsertion plutôt au contraire
augmente le non recours le stress etc on
s'étonnera comme le fait par ailleurs la
défenseur du droit surtout du vide de
moyens financiers et humains vous
prétendez mieux accompagner mais où sont
les recrutements apôle emploi votre
étude d'impact n'étudie rien du tout
absence de considération de l'impact sur
les femmes aussi qui constituent
l'imageorité l'immense majorité pardon
des allocataires du RSA majoré ça a été
dit l'absence de plantes financement
étonnant alors que vous êtes dites-vous
si soucieux de la bonne gestion publique
bref vous allez intégrer des millions de
personnes dans l'opérateur France
travail vous allez leur demander de
réaliser des heures d'activité peut-être
15 heures pour 1,9 millions de foyers ça
coûterait on peut estimer ça à 10
milliards d'euros invite de moyens qui
débouchera sur l'impossibilité
d'accompagner convenablement les
allocataires du RSA qui aura des effets
sur les salariés de Pôle emploi je l'ai
dit déjà largement en souffrance et en
sous-effectif qui vont devoir gérer
l'afflux de milliers de personnes
supplémentaires le vide c'est aussi
celui subi par tous ces jeunes de moins
de 25 ans qui devraient qui on comprend
bien votre intention contractualisée à
faire Pôle emploi pour faire des heures
sans pour autant avoir le droit au RSA
pour compenser ce vide devrait-on se
rassurer des micro-mesures qui touchent
le handicap ou la petite enfance oui oui
c'est vrai on est dans une réforme du
RSA mais voilà vous nous faites
travailler sur d'autres sujets mais nous
on aurait aimé des textes dé pour ça que
chacun de ces sujets majeurs pour
déployer une véritable ambition et
finalement une politique publique dédiée
on y reviendra avec les socialistes nous
choisirons au contraire de défendre le
droit opposable à l'accompagnement
l'inconditionnalité du RSA
l'authenticité d'un revenu minimum
d'existence fixé à un niveau décent et
ouvert au mois de 25 ans
donc choisi non pas le plein emploi mais
le vide d'emploi le mal emploi faisant
fi des freins périphériques à l'emploi
transport salaire accessibilité etc et
ce vide c'est d'ailleurs le terme
d'emploi que vous voulez faire
disparaître puisque vous renommez le
réseau et l'opérateur principal qui
s'appelait Pôle emploi en France travail
pour vous c'est donc le travail à
n'importe quel prix quitte à le faire
sans être payé pour conserver son RSA
plutôt qu'un emploi descend pour tous
votre plein emploi c'est une fine et
fabriquée à la chaîne des Daniel Blake
pour reprendre le titre du film de
kenwich ou privatisation Miss sous
contrôle et mise en concurrence des
locataires ne produit que des espoirs et
misères je vous remercie j'espère qu'on
aura l'occasion d'aller plus loin dans
le débat
merci Madame Garande pour le groupe
écologiste pardon pardon monsieur
Gernigon pour le propos horizon
monsieur le ministre madame la
Présidente mes chers collègues depuis
2017 l'ambition claire est résolue de
notre majorité a été la priorité donnée
à la politique de l'emploi aujourd'hui
il nous est présenté un projet de loi
audacieux qui s'inscrit dans une vision
à long terme
regardons les chiffres notre taux de
chômage n'a jamais été aussi bas depuis
40 ans au deuxième trimestre 2023 il est
porté à 7,2% de la population active et
1,7 millions d'emplois ont été créés
depuis 2017 cette dynamique est le fruit
de nombreuses réformes de nombreux
textes ambitieux cette tendance à la
baisse est particulièrement notable chez
nos jeunes montrant que cette vision
d'un marché du travail dynamique n'est
pas un simple idéal mais une réalité en
construction avec pour objectif le plein
emploi d'ici 2027
le rapport de préfiguration de France
travail nous a présenté un tableau qui
bien corréaliste nous interpelle il
mentionne des accompagnements peu
intensifs de suivi tardif voire plus
formal coréenne et évoque des actions
peut tourner vers l'emploi ou
l'entreprise
illustre également à quel point les
parcours peuvent être éclatés et manqués
cruellement de coordination ce sont ces
constats qui poussent à l'action
c'est pourquoi ce projet de loi au-delà
des chiffres vise une transformation
profonde avec mon ambition de renforcer
l'accompagnement vers l'emploi de chacun
et chacune tout particulièrement de ceux
qui sont les plus éloignés du monde
professionnel
cet accompagnement se doit être plus
efficace plus tangible plus personnalisé
en facilitant leur parcours
avec la création du réseau France
travail sera rendu automatique
l'inscription de toute personne sans
emploi dont les allocataires du RSA et
bénéficiaires d'un accompagnement de Cap
emploi et des missions locales
au-delà de cette simplicité l'enjeu
premier est de garantir un suivi adapté
et continue pour chacun des individu de
manière coordonnée
le contrat d'engagement unique vient
remplacer la mosaïque actuelle
clarifiant ainsi les droits et devoirs
de chacun
sur ce sujet nous soutiendrons
l'introduction d'une clause pour les 15
heures d'activité des bénéficiaires du
RSA s'assurant que cela soit adapté à
leurs besoins et difficultés
le texte porte également un ensemble de
mesures pour les travailleurs en
situation de handicap
leur taux de chômage est actuellement au
plus bas depuis 8 ans s'établissant à
12% en 2022 c'est une avancée notable
particulièrement en comparaison du taux
de chômage global qui est passé de 8% à
7 % entre juin 2021 et juin 2022
mais nous pouvons et nous devons faire
mieux
c'est pour cette raison que ce projet de
loi vise également à renforcer notre
dispositif
le titre 3 et ses articles sont
spécifiquement consacrés à faciliter
l'insertion professionnelle des
travailleurs handicapés
en outre avec ce texte en consolidant le
rôle des missions locales au sein du
réseau France travail nous reconnaissons
et amplifions leur rôle crucial
elles sont en première ligne pour
accompagner nos jeunes nécessitant un
soutien socio-professionnel il sera
également important de préciser dans le
texte que tous les jeunes suivis par les
missions locales ne sont pas en attente
d'un accompagnement professionnel et
donc n'ont pas tous vocation est inscrit
à Pôle Emploi nous soutiendrons un
amendement en ce sens
chaque mesure est le reflet dans notre
engagement a poursuivre notre objectif
du plan emploi mais avec ce texte mais
également avec d'autres qui suivront je
pense notamment aux travailleurs en
cours avec les partenaires sociaux sur
l'emploi des seniors qui sera un autre
point capital pour arriver aux objectifs
en désirs fixés le groupe horizon et
parenté soutiendra évidemment ce texte
je vous remercie
merci Madame Garin pour le groupe
écologiste
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre après la réforme de l'assurance
chômage et la réforme des retraites le
projet de loi que nous examinons à
partir d'aujourd'hui et le troisième
acte d'une politique qui vise après
cariser les plus fragiles derrière
l'argument de la centralisation de
l'information de la rationalisation je
crains que ne se cache encore en réalité
une volonté de piloter le marché du
travail pour faire coïncider à marche
forcée l'offre et la demande quel que
soit l'offre et quel que soit la demande
votre objectif c'est le plein emploi à
tout prix et à n'importe quel prix
france travail c'est la traduction d'un
logiciel productiviste au sein duquel
tout ce qui nous produit pas ne cotise
pas ne consomme pas n'a pas de valeur
j'ai nommé les jeunes les aînés les
chômeurs la pauvreté touche 9 millions
nos concitoyens dont 3 millions
d'enfants 2000 d'entre eux sont à la rue
plus de 200 dans la seule métropole de
Lyon et bien en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté on trouve les bénéficiaires du
RSA que vous visez dans ce projet de loi
aujourd'hui le RSA pour une personne
seule et de 598,54
votre réforme est aussi abjecte sur le
fond inefficace et toutes les
associations qui viennent en aide au
plus démunis là où l'État fait défaut
vont expliquer à tes déclare monde
Secours Catholique Fondation Abbé Pierre
les 34 fédérations et associations
nationales de lutte contre la pauvreté
réunis au sein du collectif Alerte
toutes dresse le même constat d'abord
les personnes les plus pauvres elles ont
avant tout besoin d'être libérées de la
peur du lendemain être pauvre c'est
avant tout une charge mentale des
privations c'est compter chaque dépense
c'est être en moins bonne santé physique
et mentale ensuite beaucoup des
bénéficiaires des minima sociaux
travaillent déjà il s'occupe par exemple
d'un parent d'un enfant en situation de
handicap il bouche les trous que vous
n'avez pas réussi à combler faute de
politique volontariste en la matière pas
assez de place en crèche pas de place en
structure dédiée ou pas assez
d'accompagnant d'élèves en situation de
handicap des lieux de vie pour les
personnes âgées bien trop cher etc etc
enfin la grande majorité des personnes
les plus pauvres souhaitent travailler
contribuer à la société mais par un
travail qui soit reconnu socialement et
qui soit rémunérés correctement or votre
projet de Loi sur l'emploi éclipse une
nouvelle fois la question du travail et
notamment celle du sens qu'on lui donne
non ce texte n'ouvre pas ce débat sinon
on se poserait les questions suivantes
pourquoi certains secteurs ne
trouvent-ils plus de candidats faut-il y
orienter les travailleurs de force et le
feront nous pour nos enfants je
soupçonne que non vous refusez de
regarder les choses en face aujourd'hui
la responsabilité des emplois non pourvu
un compte majoritairement aux employeurs
et à la nature des emplois proposés aux
conditions de travail dégradées il n'y a
rien dans cette loi à ce sujet parce que
n'allons surtout pas contraindre les
employeurs ce projet de loi fait porter
toute la responsabilité de leurs
conditions de vie aux personnes
n'arrivant pas à trouver un emploi alors
même que les inégalités de patrimoine de
parcours et de capital social sont
évidemment déterminantes dans le fait de
trouver un emploi bien rémunéré et
valoriser socialement c'est la
responsabilité de l'État de faire faire
en sorte que les plus vulnérables
puissent accéder à leurs droits vous
mentionnez monsieur le ministre les 16%
d'inscrits au RSA qui le sont encore 10
ans plus tard mais c'est notre
responsabilité c'est votre
responsabilité augmenter les contraintes
ne fait que renforcer la peur et la
stigmatisation les personnes ont avant
tout besoin d'un accompagnement
bienveillant de proximité avec quelqu'un
qui est du temps à leur consacrer ça
n'est pas avec des conseillers Pôle
emploi qui gèrent parfois plus de 100
demandeurs d'emploi qu'on n'y arrivera
j'aimerais maintenant attirer votre
attention sur les femmes elles occupent
huit emploi à temps partiel sur 10 elles
ont des métiers bien souvent précaires
elles représentent 62% des personnes
payées au SMIC et elles ont des contrats
plus hachés la quasi-totalité des
bénéficiaires du RSA majoré sont des
femmes une femme sur deux bénéficiaires
du RSA à plus d'un enfant à charge je
regrette donc une encore une fois
l'absence de mesure dédiée pourtant les
idées ne manquent pas et ne voulait
proposons régulièrement aide aux
familles monoparentales revalorisation
des emplois après dominance féminines et
prise en compte de leur pénibilité
refondu congé paternité
et non seulement vous n'activez aucune
de ces mesures pour indiquer les
phénomènes que je viens de décrire mais
les nouvelles mesures que vous comptez
mettre en œuvre risque d'aggraver la
situation
et pour finir j'aimerais vraiment que
nous prenions un peu de hauteur et que
nous réfléchissons à ce que va devenir
le travail avec le réchauffement
climatique le monde change le travail
avec lui c'est le sens de la proposition
que nous avions faite en juillet avec
notamment un droit de retrait pour les
travailleurs au-delà d'une certaine
température ce que nous avons voulu
mettre en lumière avec cette mesure
c'est la réfraction des ressources la
multiplication des événements
climatiques extrêmes la hausse des
températures que vous refusez de
regarder en face tout cela va
profondément modifier nos façons de
vivre et donc nos façons de produire et
inévitablement inévitablement de
travailler c'est notre responsabilité
d'anticiper et de proposer en
conséquence des façons d'adapter notre
modèle social et notre droit je regrette
que rien de tout cela ne soit ne
serait-ce qu'évoquée donnons-nous
davantage d'ambition que ces cinq petits
arrangements techniques qui auront
peut-être une utilité mais qui sont
vraiment très loin d'être à la hauteur
je vous remercie
merci Monsieur d'arriville pour le
groupe gauche-démocrate et républicaine
merci madame la Présidente nous sommes
convaincus de la nécessité de continuer
à lutter contre le chômage qui est
aujourd'hui encore un immense fléau
social et convaincu que ce n'est pas en
portant atteinte au droit des privés
d'emploi au droit des salariés qu'on y
parviendra or cette réforme vous l'avez
dit s'inscrit dans la droite ligne des
réformes précédentes de l'assurance
chômage qui réduisait les droits à
l'assurance chômage et même dans la
droite ligne de la réforme des retraites
qui va accroître la crise du travail et
la crise de l'emploi vous nous parlez de
plein emploi mais de quel emploi
parlez-vous on peut s'en faire une idée
en lisant le contenu du projet de loi on
pouvait déjà en avoir d'ailleurs une
idée dans le rapport de préfiguration de
France travail ou le bon emploi n'était
que subsidiaire il n'était qu'un détail
entre parenthèses page 18 du rapport en
lit tendre vers le plein entre
parenthèses et bon emploi si l'on se
contente d'un objectif qui se résume à
5% de chômage que l'on ne dit rien sur
la qualité de l'emploi visé durée
revenue droit attaché par exemple on
court le risque d'occulter une très
grande hétérogénéité des emplois et
l'inégalité des chances face à l'emploi
avec tout un ensemble de personnes
condamnées aux sous-emploi ou au mal
emploi le risque c'est celui d'une
société du plein mauvais emploi qui se
dessine avec une logique de pions à
mettre dans des cases d'aller au turbain
coûte que coûte d'adéquationnisme qui va
augmenter la souffrance au travail sans
efficacité car il y a besoin
d'accompagnement humain d'insertion de
formation pour véritablement répondre
aux besoins car si par ailleurs nous
pouvons souscrire au fait qu'il faille
clarifier les circuits rendre plus
accessibles et plus performants le
service public de l'emploi est-ce
véritablement l'objectif et le résultat
de votre projet c'est d'ailleurs aussi
ce que demande les organisations
syndicales des organismes concernés
d'abord parce que la description de
l'entité France travaille est assez
difficile à appréhender avec ses comités
à tous les échelons territoriaux son
réseau associant tous les organismes
d'accompagnement le public comme le
privé sans plus de distinction et je
veux vous interroger sur cette question
de la privatisation d'une part des
prestations du service public de
l'emploi monsieur le ministre et l'on
comprend que le comité national
président aux grandes orientations sera
en définitive entre les mains de votre
ministère cette concentration du pouvoir
a certes le mérite de simplifier la
lecture de ce que sera France travail
mais laisse perplexe sur le projet
politique sur la place des élus très
locaux sur le risque d'accroissement de
la concurrence des territoires et sur la
marge de manœuvre des différents
opérateurs qui n'ont pas tous la même
vocation les missions locales notamment
s'inquiète de voir leur mission beaucoup
plus large d'accompagnement des jeunes
dans tous les aspects de leur vie
largement entamé votre projet de loi met
également en place une simplification
qui passe par l'uniformisation tout le
monde devient d'office et un peu à
contre emploi si j'ose dire inscrit sur
les listes de demandeurs d'emploi tout
le monde est soumis donc c'est un statut
finalement que vous vous supprimez et
que vous videz de son sens tout le monde
est soumis au même contrat d'engagement
un contrat de non travail qui ne
comporte aucune réciprocité c'est-à-dire
que tout le monde est soumis à un même
régime de droit et de devoirs et surtout
de menaces de sanctions plus fortes
d'épée de Damoclès la logique c'est la
diminution du droit à choisir son emploi
d'infantilisation cette uniformisation
va invisibiliser des personnes privées
d'emploi ou en difficulté sociale et par
là au-delà même d'une expérimentation
dont on ne connaît pas le fin mot vous
organisez une confusion entre protection
sociale et solidarité nationale entre
l'allocation chômage et le RSA vous
brouillez les pistes entre le revenu de
remplacement assurantiel et le revenu de
solidarité active qui est une prestation
sociale assise sur la solidarité et
financé par l'impôt vous avez indiqué
devant le Sénat que quand le plein
emploi sera atteint il sera nécessaire
de réfléchir à la nature des allocations
qui peuvent être versées à ceux qui sont
dans une situation où l'employabilité
n'est pas possible pouvez-vous nous en
dire plus sur cette perspective afin
d'éclairer les débats il y a enfin la
question des moyens dans la lettre de
cadrage adressé aux organisations
syndicales et patronales pour la
prochaine négociation de lunédique on
découvre que c'est lunédique qui va
devoir payer des milliards d'euros
supplémentaires la contribution de
l'inédit que je cite situation à monter
en charge au fur et à mesure que le
régime dégage des excédents pour
atteindre en 2026 entre 12 et 13% des
recettes du régime au delà du fait que
vos projections macroéconomiques mais
également celles concernant l'unédicte
son sérieusement contestés il y a un
grave problème sur ce choix de
financement forme de détournement de
plus en plus massive des cotisations
inédits et des droits à l'assurance
chômage nous souhaitons une vraie loi
pour le respect du travail et de
l'humain au travail de celles et ceux
qui travaillent sur l'outre-mer vous
annoncez des mesures réglementaires
quelle est la nature des distinctions
que vous faites et je me fais le
porte-parole de nos collègues mais je
porte cette parole avec eux qui
souhaitent que soient débattu et votée
les mesures qui concernent les 10
outre-mer nous le souhaitons ici aussi
merci Monsieur sainte huile pour le
groupe
merci madame la Présidente félicitations
pour votre élection monsieur ministre
mesdames Messieurs chers collègues le
gros plus haute croit à la capacité du
travail à émanciper crois à la logique
du mérite et du coup nous nous étonnons
faisons preuve d'une forme
d'incompréhension du calendrier que vous
choisissez vous décidez de nous parler
aujourd'hui du RSA et de sa réforme
alors que nous n'avons toujours pas
parlé des salaires que nous confirmons
notre volonté de voir se tenir une
conférence sociale qui parlera de la
question du travail et de la capacité
pour ceux qui sont dans l'emploi de
pouvoir bénéficier de rémunération en
hauteur de leurs engagements si nous
aimons le travail et nous considérons
qu'il peut être un élément
d'émancipation nous regrettons aussi
avant de rentrer dans ce texte que nous
n'ayons pas eu la possibilité de
travailler sur les cas spécifiques qui
visent à ce que des gens qui retrouvent
une activité au jeu des plus et des
moins perdent une partie de leurs
revenus ce qui conduit un certain nombre
de nos compatriotes à considérer que
l'inactivité peut-être choisie et ça
c'est notre responsabilité collective
que de considérer que à chaque fois
qu'il y a activité il doit y avoir une
rémunération qui est au-delà des revenus
d'assistance en fait ce projet de loi et
cela a été dit par d'autres il s'inscrit
dans un récit politique cette espèce de
fable du plein emploi qui nous est
présenté avec l'idée que il fallait
d'abord réformer l'assurance chômage
puis revenir sur la question des
retraites pour enfin considérer que
comme nous sommes tout près du plein
emploi il est temps de fouetter le cul
de ceux qui seraient encore dans le
canapé parce qu'il bénéficierait d'un
revenu d'assistance qui serait un
confort de vie de tous les jours vous
faites un exercice compliqué parce que
dans la réalité les droits et devoirs
ils existent déjà et quand vous regardez
les chiffres que vous avez présenté les
uns et les autres monsieur le ministre
ou encore monsieur le rapporteur s'il y
a une défaillance ça n'est pas du côté
des devoirs mais bien du côté des droits
qu'il faut pouvoir la chercher je
reviendrai sur le délai entre
l'inscription et l'accompagnement sur le
nombre d'allocataires qui sont
effectivement en contrat d'engagement
réciproque ou encore ceux qui
bénéficient entre guillemets d'un
contrat dans lequel il n'y a rien sur
les questions d'activité alors bien sûr
nous nous souhaitons une meilleure
synergie sur la question de l'emploi
mais au fond
la mesure phare de ce projet c'est les
15 20h la fable absolue et vous voilà
sur le fil funambule monsieur le
ministre entre la volonté de donner
crédit et porter la voix du président de
la République de ne pas chafouiner nos
collègues et l'air et en même temps de
considérer la réalité du quotidien les
15 20h c'est impossible les uns et les
autres le savent particulièrement ceux
qui travaillent auprès des allocataires
si vous voulez parler en réalité à un
segment électoral celui des travailleurs
pauvres qui regardent ceux qui sont sans
activité comme étant une forme
d'incompréhension parce qu'ils ont le
sentiment de faire des efforts que
d'autres en font moins peut-être que ce
constat-là par moment il peut être
douloureux mais partagé alors si vous
voulez parler à ces travailleurs pauvres
il faut parler des salaires plutôt que
d'envisager de plonger encore un peu
plus dans la précarité et disons le mot
dans la pauvreté des gens qui
bénéficient entre guillemets encore une
fois d'un revenu d'assistance nous nous
sommes d'accord pour qu'il y ait un
engagement renforcé
réciproque et j'insiste sur ce
réciproque parce qu'il a disparu dans ce
texte en tant que tel nous croyons et je
le dis avec beaucoup de force à la libre
adhésion vous n'allez contraindre
personne la logique de la carotte et du
bâton ça ne fonctionne pas la condition
de la réussite c'est que la locataire il
valide un projet avec les professionnels
qui le suivent et qui se donnent le
temps de la réussite de manière générale
et pour aller à l'essentiel nous
partageons l'objectif qui est fixé sur
la question de la gouvernance de la
rapprocher des territoires je fais
partie des lieux qui ont longtemps
milité pour que les territoires soient
en capacité de peser sur les objectifs
qui sont fixés par le service public de
l'emploi sur la question des moyens cela
a été dit par les uns et les autres
c'est une condition sinequanone des
objectifs que vous fixez nous nous
étonnons que vous choisissiez la voix de
l'unédique dire un mot sur la question
étrange mais c'est sans doute un sujet
de méthode de nous expérimentons nous
n'avons pas de retour d'expérimentation
mais nous souvent en oeuvre une réforme
d'envergure peut-être que vous avez des
éléments que nous n'avons pas et que
vous permettent de voir clair je me
ferai l'écho de Pierre dareville c'est
pas toujours le cas mais en l'occurrence
la question des outre-mer pour dire que
vous choisissez l'ordonnance
l'ordonnance c'est le silence et le
silence sur ces questions là il est
inacceptable pour nos collègues
d'outre-mer et je le dis avec beaucoup
de force bien sûr il y a besoin de
différenciation mais nous savons pas de
quelle différenciation vous parlez et
nous nous souhaitons que le débat a eu
lieu en hémicycle pour pouvoir
travailler sur ces sujets de manière
générale nous nous craignons que ce
texte ça soit un texte d'affichage de
communication politique pour parler à
des segments électoraux même si par
ailleurs sur la question de la petite
enfance ou sur la question des
travailleurs handicapés il y a des
avancées qu'il nous faut pouvoir noter
mais qui aurait sans doute justifié
comprennent plus de temps sur des textes
Haddock en tant que tel pour pouvoir y
revenir je vous remercie
merci chers collègues bien pressé
nombreuses prises de parole et questions
je vais passer la parole au ministre et
ensuite on reviendra pour la suite des
questions
merci madame la Présidente merci à
toutes et à tous peut-être que je vais
essayer de répondre en regroupant les
thèmes et pardonnez-moi si un moment ou
un autre le manque d'exercice
d'exhaustivité plusieurs questions
étaient posées notamment sur le bilan
pouvant tirer d'un certain nombre de
mesures qui ont déjà été prises et je
pense notamment aux questions relatives
au bilan concernant le contrat
d'engagement jeune aujourd'hui ce contre
engagement jeune à un an et demi il
fonctionne bien dans la mesure où nous
avons eu en 2022 330 000 signatures de
contrat et donc d'entrer en contrat et
que nous sommes sur un volume qui est
comme prévu d'environ 300 000 par an les
premiers résultats que nous avons sur
les les signataires qui sont allés au
bout du parcours sont des résultats qui
sont encourageants même si je le précise
ils sont partiels puisqu'il s'agit des
premières cordes démographiques et
principalement de cordes suivies par
Pôle emploi puisque un tiers des
contrats sont suivis par Pôle emploi et
de tiers par l'émission locale nous
avons un taux de retour à l'emploi qui
est de 84% et un maintien dans le
dispositif qui est autour de 8 à 9 mois
donc c'est plutôt efficace et ça nous a
permis de démontrer que nous savons
mettre en oeuvre des dispositifs
d'accompagnement auteur de 15 amateurs
par semaine qui permettent justement
d'aller vers cet accompagnement intensif
que nous avons que nous avons voulu et
il y a en terme de public plus de la
moitié des Disney signataires qui ont un
bac ou moins que le bac en terme de
formation initiale et 9% sont mineurs ce
qui est assez logique puisque nous
sommes sur une cible 16 25 ans deuxième
dispositif que nous avons déjà mis en
oeuvre le rapprochement du réseau Pôle
emploi avec le réseau Cap emploi et
notamment l'accompagnement des personnes
en situation de handicap lorsque ce
réseau Cap Emploi a été rapproché de
Pôle Emploi cela suscité des inquiétudes
et aujourd'hui le réseau Khéops qui
coordonne l'ensemble des CAP EMPLOI
départementaux nous dit ça satisfaction
de la manière dont ça fonctionne avec
une montée en compétences des opérateurs
et des agents de Cap emploi comme des
agents de Pôle emploi avec la
constitution de portefeuille dédié et
avec une satisfaction des usagers qui
est mesurée à plus de 85% ce qui est
plutôt une bonne chose et des équipes
qui travaillent de manière très
polyvalente et rapproché dans le cas des
agences de Pôle emploi
ce que nous voulons faire avec ça c'est
démontrer que nous pouvons avoir un
réseau et un réseau en proximité avec la
volonté évidemment de ne pas tout
centrer sur les moyens qui sont donnés à
tel ou telle raison mais bien de
développer d'autres politiques en
matière d'emploi il a été évoqué
notamment la question de l'électronisme
l'électronisme est un frein et ça doit
pas être un frein à la recherche
d'emploi ça ne doit pas être un frein à
la recherche d'emploi dans le sens où
évidemment qu'il faut une présence sur
le territoire suffisamment rapproché
pour permettre l'accueil partout et nous
devons nous appuyer sur les agences de
Pôle emploi mais quand c'est possible
aussi sur l'organisation d'un certain
nombre d'accueil dans les maisons France
services là où elles existent là où
elles sont développées mais
l'électronisme doit pas être un frein de
manière générale et c'est la raison pour
laquelle dans le cadre de la nouvelle
contractualisation avec les régions sur
le plan d'investissement dans les
compétences nous souhaitons mettre la
lutte contre l'électronisme comme la
question de la lutte contre
l'illettrisme et l'analphabétisme avec
des approches parfois un peu différentes
au centre des priorités considérant
qu'il s'agit de savoir de base qui
aujourd'hui sont parmi les principaux
freins pour l'accès à l'emploi
ce plan d'investissement dans les
compétences c'est le volet formation qui
était évoqué tout à l'heure je pense
notamment à Monsieur juvain mais aussi à
Monsieur de la porte je crois pardon si
je fais une erreur dans les notes que
j'ai prises nous devons continuer à
former et à former massivement et avec
le plan d'investissement dans les
compétences nous avons multiplié par 3
le nombre de demandeurs d'emploi qui
chaque année ont accès à une formation
qualifiante et nous savons que ça marche
nous savons que ça marche parce que nous
savons qu'un demandeur d'emploi qui suit
une formation dans le cadre du pic voit
son taux de retour à l'emploi 6 mois
augmenté de 9 points et là ce qu'il
s'agit d'un demandeur d'emploi agés de
plus de 50 ans le taux de retour à
l'emploi augmente de 17 points et donc
il faut continuer ses investissements et
des investissements qui permettent de
former rapidement de donner de
l'employabilité le terme est un
néologisme n'est pas toujours ni bon ni
agréable à l'entendre mais de l'employer
habiter à ceux qui en ont besoin sur des
métiers en tension pour répondre aux
besoins de l'économie et sur des métiers
en transition pour répondre aux besoins
de l'économie demain que ce soit sur la
question de l'écologie ou sur la
question du numérique et donc c'est tout
l'objet de ce plan d'investissement dans
les compétences et c'est la raison pour
laquelle ce plan qui avait été contracté
en 2018 va être renouvelé et que dès
cette semaine les discussions sont
ouvertes avec les régions pour la mise
en oeuvre de ces nouveaux contrats y
compris en leur donnant plus de
souplesse que dans le premier notamment
sur une adaptation au territoire
régionaux et sortir d'un modèle de
répartition qui était assez uniforme
entre les différentes priorités dans le
cadre du premier contrat
cette accès à la formation est
évidemment nécessaire si nous voulons
continuer à faire baisser le chômage et
j'en profite pour faire une parenthèse
pour dire que nous avons effectivement
ce monsieur Julien qui a évoqué aussi un
taux de chômage qui nous place parmi ce
qu'on pourrait qualifié de mauvais
élèves de l'Europe en terme de taux mais
je pense que nous pouvons cependant et
c'est le cas de toujours je crois on
féliciter quand quelques années nous
sommes passés de 9,5 à 7,1 7,1 c'est
encore trop c'est encore trop et c'est
d'autant plus c'est d'autant plus un
chiffre important que nous avons dans le
même temps des difficultés de
recrutement pour les entreprises donc ça
démontre il est encore beaucoup de
travail à faire pour que l'économie qui
a créé 2 millions d'emplois en l'espace
de 6 ans puissent continuer en créer et
que nous puissions faire ce travail de
formation d'accompagnement et donc de
marche vers un taux de chômage encore
plus bas il y a une particularité au
chômage français qui est que le niveau
de tension de recrutement que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui et globalement
le même que des économies comme
l'Allemagne ou le Danemark connaissent à
trois ou quatre pour cent de chômage ce
qui renvoie peut-être une composante
structurelle de du chômage français
notamment du chômage de très longue
durée
sur les questions relatives à la place
des collectivités et à la gouvernance
j'ai dit dans mon propos introductif il
n'y a aucun article aucune disposition
qui remettent en cause la moindre
compétence des collectivités et aucun
article qui ne modifie la répartition
des compétences des collectivités entre
elles je prends un exemple pour
illustrer les présidents de conseil
départementaux sont aujourd'hui
responsables compétents pour la question
des sanctions vis-à-vis de bénéficiaire
du RSA qui seraient en situation de
manquement la sanction qui existe
aujourd'hui c'est la radiation à l'issue
d'une commission pluridisciplinaire
demain nous proposons de créer un
dispositif de suspension le rapporteur
Paul Christophe la décrit parfaitement
avec la possibilité d'un versement
rétroactif et une grande réactivité dans
la mise en oeuvre comment va fonctionner
ce dispositif lorsque un
agent lors un travers social du
département fera la proposition de
suspension comme aujourd'hui il fait une
proposition de radiation le président du
département sera compétent pour un
décide lorsqu'on agent Pôle emploi
devenu France travail fera une
proposition de sus cela restera le
président du département qui sera
compétent pour en décider et le
président du Département pourra si le
souhaite et avec la corde son conseil
départemental délégué la décision à
France travail mais s'il ne délègue pas
il le restera compétent pour décider des
suites qu'ils donnent ou pas à la
proposition de suspension proposée par
un agent de Pôle emploi au France
travail et sur la question du pilotage
je l'ai dit aussi aujourd'hui les
régions les départements l'ensemble des
niveaux de collectivité ne participent
pas à l'élaboration des orientations du
service public de l'emploi tant au
niveau national régional départemental
et local nous souhaitons demain que ce
soit possible pour définir les
orientations et qu'ensuite Pôle Emploi
France travaille comme opérateur est en
charge la mise en oeuvre des
orientations décidées par le comité dans
lequel siègeront l'État les
collectivités à tous les niveaux mais
aussi les partenaires sociaux au niveau
national et régional et donc c'est
plutôt une capacité à peser sur les
orientations que nous donnons aux
collectivité plutôt que un quelconque un
quelconque modification de leur de leurs
compétences
sur la question des systèmes
d'information et
de leur utilité toute l'utilité et
l'utilité principale c'est bien d'éviter
les ruptures de parcours et d'éviter que
des parcours vers l'emploi ouvert la
formation soit fait et refait
aujourd'hui lorsque un jeune est suivi
par une mission locale et uniquement par
une mission locale qui pour des
questions d'âge parfois et qui rejoint
un pôle emploi le dossier doit être prêt
à zéro avoir un système horizontal c'est
aussi la garantie que chacun des
conseils à tout moment du parcours
puisse avoir accès aux informations sur
les formations réalisées sur
l'accompagnement dans ta bénéficiaire la
personne concernée et ainsi avoir
quelque chose de plus efficace et qui
nous permet d'éviter et les ruptures et
les sorties de dispositif
dans le cadre de cet accompagnement il y
a la question des 15 à 20h cette
question des 15 amateurs est importante
et le président de la République l'avait
dit pendant sa campagne présidentielle
elle s'articule autour de trois points
le premier point c'est que le RSA est
une aide inconditionnelle qui est
inconditionne dès lors qu'on remplit de
critères économiques et financiers
notamment de privation de ressources une
fois que le RSA est une fois que la
personne est éligible au RSA il y a et
c'est la loi aujourd'hui la nécessité de
signer un contrat d'engagement la
réalité que seulement 47% des
allocataires signent un contrat
d'engagement aujourd'hui non pas parce
qu'il refuse mais parce que ça ne
l'aurait pas proposé donc notre objectif
et que ce contrat d'engagement puisse
être proposé à tous et que dans le cadre
de ce contrat il y a un parcours qui
soit adapté un parcours adapté en tenant
compte des possibilités de chacun le
Sénat applique ça un objectif à 15 20
heures qui qui s'appliquerait absolument
tout le monde quel que soit la situation
j'ai entendu dans les interventions des
uns et des autres la nécessité de tenir
compte des demandeurs d'emploi en
situation de handicap des familles
monoparentales mais au-delà et il y un
certain nombre de personnes un locataire
du RSA qui vont être confrontés à
d'énormes difficultés de mobilité à des
problèmes de santé qui ne relèvent pas
le nécessairement d'un handicap reconnu
comme tel mais à un moment de maladie de
difficulté à des problèmes de garde
d'enfant dans le cas des familles
monoparentales nous devons tenir compte
à la fois pour nous fixer un objectif
très ambitieux parce que ce niveau de 15
20h et celui qui permet véritablement la
plus grande mobilisation mais en ayant
bien conscience les uns et les autres
que nous devons l'atteindre parfois
progressivement mais au fil des
interventions je pense que le travail et
le débat pourront nous permettre
d'aboutir à quelque chose qui soit
équilibré nous allons tout faire tout
cela en disposant de moyens nouveaux je
les dis dans le cadre de la
contractualisation avec les départements
sur France travail ce sens 170 millions
d'euros Pôle Emploi va bénéficier dès
2024 de 300 millions d'euros
supplémentaires et je souligne que Pôle
emploi a bénéficié au cours des cinq
dernières années de 4000 créations de
poste dans une période où le nombre de
demandeurs d'emploi inscrit avaient
tendance à baisser et donc nous allons
continuer à déployer à déployer ses
moyens comment nous les finançons nous
les finançons à la fois par la
subvention de l'État à Pôle emploi mais
aussi je l'ai dit par un prélèvement sur
les excédents de lunédique les excédents
que nous souhaitons prélever et nous
l'avons dit aux partenaires sociaux
n'empêcheront pas dans l'hypothèse où
nous allons au bout de cette discussion
avec eux n'empêcheront pas lunédique de
voir sa dette divisée par deux d'ici
2027 dans le cas de nos projections et
donc nous arrivons à la fois à
participer au financement de politique
pour l'emploi qui sont une forme de
dépenses active puisque nous savons qu'à
chaque fois que nous permettons de
raccompagner quelqu'un ou d'accompagner
quelqu'un vers l'emploi c'est moins
d'allocation c'est plus de cotisations
et c'est un modèle vertueux pour les
contes de lunédique sans remettre en
cause la perspective de désendettement
de lunédique
c'est un premier point sur lequel nous
devons avancer et c'est un point sur
lequel je pense que nous aurons les
moyens de réussir ce pari de la montée
en puissance progressive et en termes de
généralisation pas avant le 1er janvier
2025 de cette de ce nouvel
accompagnement je fais un lien avec la
question des expérimentations ça a été
dit Monsieur c'est un tulle l'a dit dans
la dernière intervention
pourquoi vous votez la loi aujourd'hui
alors que les expérimentations sont en
cours les expérimentations que nous
menons avec 18 conseils départementaux
qui ont retenu chacun un bassin d'emploi
l'exception d'un département la Creuse
pour laquelle pour lequel
l'expérimentation est à l'échelle
départementale pour des questions
démographiques si nous voulons ces
expérimentations et si nous les faisons
maintenant c'est parce que ces
expérimentations sont sur des modalités
d'accompagnement qui n'ont aucun
caractère réglementaire ou législatif
lorsqu'il s'agit de voir comment
améliorer les parcours le suivi quel
type d'activité proposé il est
impensable à mes yeux en tout cas
d'écrire dans la loi quelles sont la
nature des activités d'insertion et de
formation qui vont être mises en oeuvre
nous disons que ça n'est pas du travail
gratuit nous disons que ce n'est pas du
bénévole obligatoire mais nous ne
pouvons pas aller dans le détail des
propositions ceux d'entre vous qui ont
lu le rapport de Thibault guili ont pu
voir qu'en annexe il était présenté
toute une liste de possibilités
d'exemples d'activités extrêmement
variés plus de 150 que nous n'allons pas
écrire dans la loi par contre nous avons
beaucoup de travailler avec l'Assemblée
des départs de France début 2024 nous
ferons un premier point d'étape de bilan
sur les évaluations les expérimentations
qui ont été ouvertes pour la plupart au
1er avril 2023 nous allons élargir
quelques peuples cette expérimentation
et j'ai proposé au Président de
l'Assemblée des départements de France
que les modalités de sélection de
définition des nouveaux territoires
inclus soient réalisés en lien très
étroit avec le bureau de l'Assemblée des
départements de France et ces
expérimentations dureront jusqu'à fin
2024 pour nous permettre de connaître
les meilleures pratiques d'avancer sans
qu'il y ait besoin d'un caractère
législatif si à l'issue de cette
expérimentation telle ou telle
disposition nécessité de les inscrire
dans un texte nous le ferions mais à mon
sens quand on parle d'accompagnement et
de programmes d'accompagnement ça n'a
pas de caractère législatif aux
réglementaires sur la question des
opérateurs privés de placement et donc
du secteur de l'emploi le texte
n'apporte rien de nouveau et
continueront à accompagner le service
public de l'emploi comme ils le font
aujourd'hui sans qu'il est la moindre
modification c'est la même chose mais
dans un autre domaine pour les missions
locales je l'ai dit aussi
les modalités de financement restent les
mêmes conventionnement avec l'État les
compétences des missions locales
monsieur d'arriville il a évoqué le
sujet tout à l'heure reste les mêmes
notamment sur l'accueil et
l'accompagnement intégral et complet des
jeunes et nous avons veillé y compris
dans les dernières
derniers arbitrage sur le texte a bien
préciser que c'était un exercice de
compétence de plein droit et non pas par
délégation de tel ou tel donc le modèle
de compétences d'émission locale comme
leur gouvernance n'est pas ne sont pas
concerné par le texte c'est pas affecté
par le texte la seule différence pour
les missions locales elle est double en
réalité c'est l'accès un système
d'information horizontale qui ne ce
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui plutôt des
informations nouvelles et c'est la
participation au comité France travail à
la quasi-totalité des niveaux et donc la
participation la définition des
orientations qu'elle mettrons ensuite en
oeuvre alors qu'aujourd'hui elles sont
absentes de ce travail de définition des
orientations c'est plutôt un mieux
en la matière
sur les autres points qui ont été
évoqués et notamment sur la question des
autres débats qui pourraient être
abordés avant ou pendant ce texte vous
le savez à l'issue de la rencontre avec
les chefs de party le président de la
République annoncé la tenue d'une
conférence sociale elle se tiendra la
semaine du 16 octobre et nous
travaillons actuellement avec les
partenaires sociaux pour en déterminer
l'ordre du jour la question des
négociations de branches la question de
la classification qui permet de garantir
une progression salariale à l'échelle
d'une carrière les questions relatives
au temps partiel subies et donc aux
sous-emploi les questions relatives à
l'évolution des salaires et du SMIC sur
plusieurs années mais aussi aux
conséquences aux interférences entre
cette évolution des salaires et du SMIC
en son sein avec l'augmentation la
montée en puissance de la prime
d'activité ou encore les sorties de
tunnels d'exonération seront inscrites
tout comme la question de l'égalité
professionnelle dans cette conférence
sociale tout en gardant à l'esprit que
nous restons attachés à un modèle qui
est le modèle français détermination des
salaires qui est que le SMIC connaît une
indexation qui est arrêté par la loi et
que nous mettons évidemment en œuvre et
qu'ensuite il y a la négociation de
bronches pour déterminer le niveau de
des rémunérations de la même manière
nous devons travailler et là aussi c'est
un dans l'intervention de Monsieur
scintuel sur les conditions de reprise
d'emploi
aujourd'hui un certain nombre de
personnes qui bénéficient ou en tout cas
qui survivent grâce à des minima sociaux
on le sentiment qui n'est pas rentable
qui n'est pas efficace de reprendre un
emploi c'est parfois vrai et c'est
parfois vrai non pas de manière générale
parce que nous avons des modèles qui
montrent que la reprise d'emploi va
plutôt dans le bon sens c'est pas vrai
de manière temporaire parce que les
coûts liés à la reprise d'emploi la
perte de droit liée à la reprise
d'emploi sont souvent plus rapides que
la mise en place des nouveaux droits
liés à au fait de percevoir un salaire
de au niveau du SMIC ou légèrement
au-dessus du SMIC et donc il faut qu'on
travaille sur ces tuilages pour faire en
sorte que la reprise d'emploi soit
toujours plus intéressante immédiatement
et pas trois quatre ou cinq mois comme
c'est parfois le cas
je termine par deux points tout en
sachant évidemment que je n'ai pas été
trois points pardon dans sachant que je
n'ai pas été exhaustif d'abord un point
pour dire que il est évidemment hors de
question pour nous de stigmatiser qui
que ce soit je pense que au contraire
lorsqu'on investit dans l'accompagnement
dans la formation et dans l'insertion on
est à la on est au rendez-vous de la
solidarité de la réelle solidarité celle
qui consiste à ne pas laisser les gens
dans une trappe à précarité une trappe à
pauvreté et je ne connais pas de
meilleure façon de sortir la pauvreté
que l'emploi et l'accès à un revenu
salarié en plus de l'émancipation et
l'autonomie que ça procure la deuxième
chose que je voulais aussi souligner
concerne les mesures relatives au
handicap pour remercier l'ensemble des
intervenants qui nous ont dit leur
intérêt pour ces mesures et le fait
qu'elles vont dans le bon sens qui est
évidemment une réalité dont je suis
heureux mais c'est le fruit des travaux
de la CNH et enfin un troisième point
pour dire que lorsqu'on s'interroge sur
la reprise d'emploi et sur quel emploi
c'était notamment une question de
Monsieur d'arriville la qualité de
l'emploi aujourd'hui c'est améliorer je
crois qu'on peut s'en féliciter je
prends simplement un chiffre pour
l'illustrer pour la première fois en
2022 la part des CDI dans les signatures
de contrat et l'indice statistique a
toujours retenu les signatures de
contrat d'un mois ou plus d'un mois à
passer le cap des 50%. c'est la première
fois nous étions entre 43 et 46% de
manière régulière et nous sommes à plus
de 50% de CDI dans les premiers contrats
signes et ça s'est accompagné pour la
première fois aussi du fait que dans
l'emploi privé en France aujourd'hui
pour la première fois depuis plus de 30
ans nous avons une part majoritaire de
CDI dans le total de l'emploi privé ça
signifie que les créations d'emplois que
nous avons connues au cours des six
dernières années ce sont accompagnés
d'une amélioration de l'emploi et je
pense que les conditions économiques ils
font pour beaucoup évidemment mais que
les politiques que nous avons mis en
place notamment autour du bonus malus il
contribue et puis enfin parce que je ne
voudrais pas
pardon madame la Présidente c'est aussi
monsieur daryville qui m'a posé une
question elle est elle est importante
sur une de mes déclarations au Sénat qui
disait quand on aura atteint plein
emploi il faudra qu'on s'interroge sur
le fait que des hommes et des femmes
restent durablement sur des dispositifs
comme le RSA et s'interroger sur la
nature de l'activité ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que nous savons que parmi
les presque 2 millions d'allocataires du
RSA nous avons des hommes et des femmes
qui sont très très profondément et très
violemment abîmée par la vie et que
certains d'entre eux sont aussi
confrontés à des problématiques de santé
mentale qui sont très souvent mal pris
en compte dans nos systèmes de manière
générale et ce que je crois c'est que
peut-être que parmi eux mais nous le
saurons lorsque nous aurons fait ce
travail de d'aller vers le plein emploi
et lorsque nous aurons accompagné tout
ce que nous pouvons accompagner faudra
qu'on s'interroge en disant mais s'il y
a une difficulté qui est véritablement
trop importante pour être surmonté
est-ce que ça n'est pas un peu hypocrite
de maintenir ces personnes sur des
revenus de solidarité qui renvoient
l'activité l'insertion professionnelle
est-ce qu'il n'y a pas d'autres
dispositifs plus adapté ou à créer pour
tenir compte de la réalité de leur
situation et de la réalité d'une
difficulté durable pour ne pas dire
insurmontable c'est un débat qui viendra
après mais qui viendra nécessairement
parce que nous le savons et ça serait
une hypocrisie de ne pas l'assumer que
parmi les allocataires du RSA certains
malheureusement ont une ville qui les a
trop exposées pour pouvoir remonter la
pente au même rythme même à l'échelle du
même à l'échelle d'une vie donc faisons
ce travail là et lorsque nous lancerons
à ce stade je pense que nous aurons les
moyens de mieux les accompagner
merci monsieur le ministre pour
l'ensemble de ces réponses nous avons
encore de nombreuses questions
je passe la parole à Thibault Bazin en
vous demandant à tous d'être vigilants
sur le respect du temps les deux minutes
merci beaucoup
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre au-delà du titre prometteur je
souhaite vous interroger à mon tour sur
trois axes qui à mon sens gagnerait à
être renforcé afin de vraiment atteindre
le plein emploi sinon on risque un peu
de faire semblant tout en amenuisant
l'effectivité de l'objectif affiché que
nous partageons le premier axe concerne
la valorisation du travail a même
densité durablement à l'emploi il y a un
an vous aviez convenu ici que certains
citoyens en reprenant un travail pouvait
pour des raisons de seuil par la perte
de certaines allocations gagnez moins à
court terme au moins temporairement vous
venez d'ailleurs d'évoquer 4 à 5 mois si
on ne valorise pas le mieux le travail
nous peinerons à atteindre le plein
emploi et ce projet de loi s'avérera
bien insuffisant en parallèle de ce
projet de loi prévoyez-vous une réforme
structurelle pour que les revenus du
travail soient toujours bien supérieur
aux aides sociales le deuxième axe
concerne la coordination des nouvelles
instances créées par ce projet de loi
avec les communes et les
intercommunalités par exemple un article
premier pourquoi ne pas y inclure les
intercommunalités et les communes qui
exercent bien souvent des compétences en
matière de mobilité ou d'accueil du
jeune enfant qui sont des un vrai frein
au retour à l'emploi
dans le même esprit leur regard serait
précieux pour accompagner les missions
de repérage et d'accompagner en
spécifiques qui sont prévus à l'article
tri 6 êtes-vous prêt à élargir également
pour les communes l'accès aux
informations du nouveau système
d'information concernant les demandeurs
d'emploi le troisième axe d'amélioration
concerne les mesures de l'article 10
pour les familles si on ne peut que
soutenir votre volonté de renforcer les
solutions d'accueil des enfants je
m'interroge sur la pertinence de deux
des paramètres tenus et les
compensations financières à garantir par
l'État pourquoi retenir trois ans et pas
six ans ou 10 ans à ces âges beaucoup de
parents ont encore besoin de solutions
de garde notamment avant ou après le
début de la classe ou pendant les
vacances scolaires qui laissera un
enfant seul à 4 ans ensuite vous les
définir des zones caractérisées par
niveau d'offre d'accueil du jeune enfant
particulièrement élevé afin d'illimiter
les projets une telle disposition ne
risque-t-elle pas de s'avérer injuste un
tel niveau d’œuf n'est bien souvent pas
le fruit du hasard mais s'obtient dans
certains territoires vertueux par
l'engagement Ford des familles et des
collectivités territoriales attention à
ne pas les pénaliser en manquant votre
cible
merci chers collègues Monsieur Le Gac
oui merci le présidente monsieur le
ministre comme beaucoup ici j'ai
consulté ces dernières semaines pour
préparer ce projet de loi j'ai rencontré
des élus la Mission Locale Pôle emploi
des associations intermédiaires de mon
département et je crois pouvoir dire
aujourd'hui qu'il y a un quasi
uneanimité pour dire qu'on est fait il
faut une meilleure coordination des
différents acteurs pour rendre plus
efficace les politiques d'insertion et
de retour à l'emploi et notamment bien
évidemment de ceux qui sont le plus
éloignés du marché du travail il est pas
acceptable de laisser passer parfois
plusieurs mois entre le moment où un
allocataire s'inscrit
au RSA le premier entretien où il pourra
enfin évoquer sa situation au cours de
ces échanges un sujet revient souvent
vous l'avez évoqué dans votre propos
liminaire c'est bien évidemment le choix
de l'échelon le plus pertinent pour être
associé à la gouvernance locale de
France travail bon de manière générale
je pense qu'il faut privilégier à mon
avis les bassins de vie et que donc les
EPCI constituent sans doute l'échelon le
plus pertinent pour le pilotage local de
de ces politiques les EPCI sont déjà
compétentes en matière de développement
économique et social de logements de
transport et de mobilité et pour la
plupart elles sont déjà engagées bien
évidemment dans des actions en faveur de
l'emploi et même pour 40 % d'entre elles
en matière de petit enfant
j'ai bien noté vous l'avez rappelé tout
à l'heure la souplesse dans le choix de
cet échelon vous l'avez rappelé à
plusieurs reprises j'ai bien noté aussi
que chaque collectivité conservait ses
compétences qui la formation qui
l'insertion qui l'action sociale de
proximité mais alors pouvez-vous
repréciser aujourd'hui et avant le début
de nos débats quand et à quel moment
sera défini cet échelon et surtout qui
va arbitrer en cas de désaccord merci
monsieur le ministre
merci Monsieur Freddy certain
ministre
c'est un projet de loi attendu je crois
que la France effectivement a besoin de
faire mieux en matière de recherche de
mise en activité des uns des autres je
déplore que beaucoup d'amendements
étaient non recevables me concernant
alors que sur un sujet comme celui-ci il
était utile me semble-t-il de pouvoir
être force de proposition et
probablement d'élargir le spectre de
votre projet de loi plein emploi certes
mais j'ai un peu le sentiment que ça
repose encore sur un modèle économique
un peu un peu obsolète le plein emploi
certes mais aussi l'activité
professionnelle sur ses formes je pense
en particulier au travail indépendant
les femmes des hommes non salariés qui
néanmoins proposent des biens et des
services qui actuellement sont
confrontés à une insécurité juridique en
raison d'un statut qui reste hybride qui
reste confronté à des blocages et il me
paraissait nécessaire dans le cadre de
ce projet de loi probablement d'évoquer
quelque chose et de faire progresser
notre droit à la matière je pense
également à l'emploi des seniors il
était à mon avis opportun de marquer une
volonté politique et des dispositions
très concrètes sur ce sujet qui ne
préoccupe
et puis je j'en ai faite à la semaine
passée lors de différentes auditions je
je m'étonne qu'il n'y ait pas le mot
insertion ou inclusion insertion
professionnelle dans un projet de loi
qui porte sur le plein emploi on sait
très bien que même si le marché du
travail est optimisé organisé avec
peut-être une autre recherche
d'efficacité pour des hommes et des
femmes s'il n'y a pas de parcours il n'y
arriveront pas et on n'ira pas au plein
emploi donc un sentiment peut-être de
d'oubli d'absence de plénitude dans le
cadre de votre projet loi même si
globalement il coche un certain nombre
de cases il fallait refonder le RSA la
Cour des comptes l'a dit depuis 2022 des
opérateurs de terrain l'ont dit il est
insupportable inadmissible de laisser
des allocateurs sans accompagnement
ça veut dire qu'on cautionne exclusion
donc on verra quelle sera l'atterrissage
mais en l'état
les débats devront éclairer un certain
nombre d'interrogations qui sont encore
les miennes
merci Madame Vidal merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre notre
politique en faveur de l'emploi et de
l'insertion porte ses fruits et ce texte
vient y contribuer avec clarté
aujourd'hui nombre d'entreprises se sont
engagés pour une meilleure conciliation
entre vie privée et vie professionnelle
c'est fondamental et notamment je pense
au prochain dents l'expérimentation du
relayage à domicile dit baluchonnage que
nous avons voté dans la loi du dissout
2018 pour un état au service d'une
société de confiance va dans ce sens car
elle permet des prestations de
suppléance de l'aidant au domicile de la
personne accompagnée grâce aux
dérogations au droit du travail qui ont
été prises ce relayage à domicile avec
un intervenant unique qui est essentiel
pour l'accompagnement des personnes
aidées c'est également une solution de
répit de longue durée utile pour les
aidants et elle offre finalement des
nouvelles possibilités d'organisation de
travail pour les professionnels
volontaires
l'expérimentation se termine le 31
décembre chambre et à ce stade rien
n'est prévu pour pouvoir pérenniser ce
dispositif alors Monsieur le Ministre
j'ai bien compris que ce sujet ne pourra
pas être débattu pendant ce texte mais
comment pourrions-nous répondre à cette
demande des professionnels des
procédants et des aînés pour pouvoir
pérenniser ce baluchonnage à la
française si appréciée je vous remercie
merci Monsieur aviranier oui merci
le ministre mes chers collègues nous
reprenons nos travaux parlementaires par
l'examen de ce projet de loi pour le
plein emploi alors que les Français sont
pris la gorge que l'inflation ne cesse
leur pourrir la vie que nos services
publics sont sans dessus dessous quelle
est la priorité du gouvernement pour
cette rentrée attaquer les plus proches
de concitoyens les stigmatiser et les
infantilisés alors monsieur le ministre
vous qui avez été un temps socialiste
comment pouvez-vous porter une loi qui
sape à ce point l'héritage François
Mitterrand et de Michel ro dois-je vous
rappeler les propos de François
Mitterrand lors de la création du RMI en
88 qui disait l'important est un moyen
de vivre plutôt de survivre soit
garantie à ceux qui n'ont rien car le
RMI puis le RSA n'ont jamais été conçu
comme un salaire mais comme un revenu
minimum vital pour survivre pas vivre je
dis bien survivre et à travers cette loi
vous allez transformer le RSA un salaire
inférieur au SMIC et c'est dangereux
alors oui imposer une activité minimum
de 15 à 20h par semaine sans réelle
accompagnement ce n'est pas redonné de
la dignité au bénéficiaires du RSA ni
leur permettent de retrouver un travail
digne c'est créer des travailleurs en
dessous du SMIC sans assumer ouvertement
vous allez faire exploser le nombre de
personnes en grande précarité vous
l'avez déjà largement augmenté avec vos
différentes réformes comme en témoignent
la fut massif de nouveaux bénéficiaires
des Restos du cœur en métropole comme
dans les territoires d'outre-mer
d'ailleurs à ce sujet c'est bizarre mais
ce sont des constat que vous ne faites
jamais punir les pauvres d'être pauvre
est une aberration aussi bien éthique
économique le prix Nobel Esther du flot
la démontré à travers l'exemple
britannique ne suivons pas le même
chemin Funès monsieur le ministre
vraisemblablement leur stérilité
budgétaire nous attend et ma question
sera donc simple à hauteur de combien le
gouvernement compte financer cette
conditionnalisation du RSA en embauchant
massivement des conseillers Pôle emploi
et en finissant des formations et des
stages présents locataires
[Musique]
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre vous venez de dire quelque
chose à l'instant parmi les allocataires
du RSA certains sont violemment abîmés
par la vie et confrontés à des
problématiques de santé mentale vous
jugez nécessaire de s'interroger sur la
masse sur le maintien d'un dispositif
qui renvoie à l'insertion
professionnelle il y avait une
expérimentation qui avait été mise en
place justement pour savoir si ce que
vous proposez ne va pas avoir une
conséquence néfaste pour ces personnes
qui ont été brisées par la vie et dont
la question de la réadaptation se pose
mais dans la mesure où ces
expérimentations ne sont pas terminées
et que votre réforme va s'appliquer
est-ce que à demi-mot vous n'êtes pas en
train d'admettre que l'une de ces
conséquences c'est que ces personnes
brisées par la vie ayant souvent des
problèmes de santé mentale se verront
avoir un revenu tout simplement supprimé
et termineront à la rue c'est pour ça
qu'on les critique du dispositif et vous
venez d'admettre à demi-mots que vous
allez faire une expérimentation grandeur
nature sur les publics les plus fragiles
de notre pays et que vous les priverez
tout simplement de revenus vous verrez
plus tard comment est-ce qu'on les
réinsérer est-ce que vous pouvez
préciser votre pensée d'apprenti sorcier
sur la vie des gens qui nous apparaît
choquantes pour le début de ces débats
monsieur Fernandez
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre en novembre dernier lors
d'une question gouvernement je disais de
vous que vous étiez lentilles Ambroise
Croizat alors que vous portiez déjà un
projet de loi foncièrement antisocial en
l'occurrence une attaque historique
contre l'assurance chômage depuis vous
avez repoussé l'âge de la retraite à 74
ans contre la volonté de l'immense
majorité du pays aujourd'hui vous
poursuivez votre œuvre de destruction de
la solidarité et de la dignité si chère
à votre illustre prédécesseur nous
sommes dans un pays où plus de 8
millions de personnes ont recours à
l'aide alimentaire chiffres en constante
augmentation au point que les nations
les associations caritatives n'arrivent
plus à suivre une baisse de 17% de la
consommation alimentaire dans le pays
inédite depuis plus de 40 ans avec un
tiers du pays qui ne mange plus à sa fin
oui une part importante du pays est
contrainte de se serrer la ceinture
parallèlement la fortune cumulée des 500
plus riches du pays et qui vaut
aujourd'hui à 45% pas loin de la moitié
du PIB donc la richesse produite
annuellement par la totalité du pays
cette fortune cumulée a plus que doublé
depuis l'accession à la présidence de la
République d'Emmanuel Macron alors le
gouvernement pourrait se dire il y a un
grave problème de répartition des
richesses réglons-le réglons ce problème
on peut pas accepter qu'un tiers du pays
se sert la ceinture et que les 500 plus
riches se gavent nous sommes ici en
commission des affaires sociales nous
pourrions y travailler et bien non vous
choisissez à nouveau de vous attaquer au
plus précaire au plus vulnérable à
celles et ceux et surtout celles
d'ailleurs ça a été dit qui ont le moins
vous stigmatisez vous humilier vous
entretenir vous entretenez l'idée crasse
que celles et ceux qui sont au minima
sociaux sont des fainéants qui profitent
du système alors qu'elles et ils sont en
mode survie alors ma question est simple
n'avez-vous pas honte et singulièrement
vous monsieur le ministre qui en 2017
Vautier contre les budgets d'Emmanuel
Macron et pour quelques jours plus tard
rejoint le gouvernement pour les mettre
en œuvre
monsieur Clouet
merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues monsieur le ministre on parle
ici de votre projet intitulé donc France
travail mais ce projet me semble qu'il a
déjà commencé au mois de juillet lorsque
toutes les salariés et salariés du pays
ont reçu sur leur bulletin de paie une
surprise à savoir l'apparition une
nouvelle ligne qui s'appelle le montant
net social j'invite évidemment toutes
les personnes à regarder chez elle sur
leur bulletin de Pace qu'il en est ce
monte en aide sociale donc une ligne
ajoutée en bas du bulletin de paie
regroupe ce qu'il faut déclarer pour
pouvoir bénéficier du RSA ou de la prime
d'activité lorsqu'on est en emploi ce
montant net qu'est-ce qu'il recoupe et
bien le salaire net qu'on connaît très
bien qui est écrit en gros sur la fiche
de paye mais également les tickets resto
la prévoyance la participation patronale
à la garde d'enfant etc plein de choses
que la CAF ne demandait pas avant pour
pouvoir postuler au RSA ou pour pouvoir
postuler à la prime d'activité donc ça
signifie que depuis juillet avec un même
salaire et bien votre montant net fiscal
et supérieur cela signifie donc en voie
de conséquence qu'avec un même salaire
et bien le revenu qui peut être touché
en RSA ou le revenu qui peut être touché
en prime d'activité baisse il y a eu
plein d'exemples donnés par les
syndicats j'en prends un que la CFDT a
mentionné dans le dernier numéro de
libération une salarié qui s'appelle
Martine dont le net à payer et de 1599 €
par mois mais son aide sociale
puisqu'elle bénéficie davantage en
nature et lui de 1765 donc sa prime
d'activité est divisée par deux et elle
perd 65 euros alors qu'elle fait le même
boulot depuis le 1er juillet que le jour
d'avant bref ma question est donc assez
simple combien de gens ont d'ores et
déjà depuis deux mois perdu de l'argent
en matière de RSA combien de gens ont
perdu de l'argent avec la prime
d'activité et parmi elles parmi eux
combien ont tout perdu combien ne sont
plus éligibles ni au rsa ni la prime
d'activité quelle est la perte en
moyenne bref finalement la question on
pourrait la résumer de la manière
suivante quand est-ce et comment
comptez-vous leur rendre leur argent
madame Amrani
chers collègues monsieur le ministre
nous avons aujourd'hui la présentation
d'un projet de loi profondément
antisocial un texte qui dans la droite
ligne qui est dans la droite ligne de la
réforme des retraites à des objectifs
irréalisables un texte qui s'attaque au
privé d'emploi plutôt qu'à la rareté de
l'emploi monsieur le ministre après
avoir radié les chômeurs vous vous
prenez maintenant aux allocataires du
RSA monsieur le ministre ma question
porte sur la programmation budgétaire de
ce PGL le rapport de concertation
prévoit seulement la mobilisation de
3,2,3 à 2,7 milliards d'euros de
financement cumulés sur une période de
2024 à 2026 pourtant selon les acteurs
de l'insertion il faudrait 4 milliards
d'euros par an pour tenir les objectifs
d'accompagnement France travail
s'agissant de des expérimentations elles
ont été financées à hauteur de 22
millions soit 550 euros par allocataire
alors que le rapport France travail un
projette un investissement de 10000
euros par an et par allocataire la
réalité monsieur le ministre c'est qu'à
ce jour nous n'avons absolument aucune
garantie sur le budget qui sera
réellement alloué à la formation et au
recrutement des agents nous pouvons
d'ores et déjà présager que les
allocataires du RSA risque de subir des
contrôles bien plus renforcés que les
sangles et que les sanctions seront plus
dures dans le service public de l'emploi
qui n'aura de public que son nom avec
des objectifs irréalistes et surtout
démagogiques à contresens en tout cas
des besoins réels des citoyennes et des
citoyens de ce pays monsieur le ministre
je vous pose la question y a-t-il une y
a-t-il une vraie programmation
budgétaire sérieuse et viable pour
accompagner votre projet de loi
France travail je vous remercie
merci Madame kéké merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre vous
venez aujourd'hui nous parler de votre
de votre nouveau projet de loi plein
emploi quelle beauté mais comment
atteindre le plein emploi en mettant en
place les 32 heures réclamés par les
salariés et leurs syndicat non en
revenant sur votre honteuse réforme des
retraites à 64 ans avec un retour à la
retraite à 60 ans non en augmentant les
salaires pour sauver le pouvoir d'agent
de la population là encore non mais que
proposez-vous alors et bien vous
proposez la guerre sociale la guerre au
plus précaire la guerre aux pauvres à
celle et ceux qui touchent le RSA et
ceux qui galèrent et qui souffrent déjà
au quotidien
vous vous instaurez le travail gratuit
qui va déstabiliser les emplois et
aggraver le don'tis social c'est le
monde du travail et l'ensemble de la
société que vous allez tirer vers le bas
c'est contraintes les gens à travailler
dans n'importe quelle condition et pour
un salaire de misère monsieur le
ministre quel est pour vous la
définition du plein emploi option 1
lorsque tous les demandeurs d'emploi
sont radiés de Pôle emploi ou celle du
bon sens lorsque tout le monde a un
emploi
merci madame la Présidente merci
Monsieur Catteau merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues voici un nouveau texte
sur l'emploi avec lui de nouvelles
promesses de nouveaux espoirs mais aussi
nouvelle déshylusion monsieur le
ministre il est vrai que nous commençons
à avoir l'habitude de vos projets de loi
incompatibles incomplet brouillon
déconnecté de la réalité des Français
comment allez-vous expliquer à nos
compatriotes qui après avoir cotisé
chaque mois sur leur salaire au titre de
l'assurance chômage que leurs droits
seront désormais conditionnés à un
contrat d'engagement de 15 ans
d'activité hebdomadaire comment les veut
expliquer aux maires qui élèvent leurs
enfants seuls
osez donc qui s'occupent de leurs
proches que leur seul revenu la maigre
petite aide qu'il est sort à peine de la
pauvreté pour alors être retiré parce
qu'ils n'auront pas de temps de
satisfaire les exigences de ce contrat
comment pouvez-vous infliger à ceux que
vous avez déjà floué lors de votre
réforme des retraites à ceux qui
subissent de plein fouet l'inflation et
la perte continue de leur pouvoir
d'achat à ceux qui endurent en première
ligne la montée de l'insécurité et l'en
sauvagement de la société
comment allez-vous expliquer au
conseiller Pôle emploi la considablement
la considérable augmentation de leur
charge de travail du fait du suivi
intensif de l'ensemble des demandeurs
d'emploi par ailleurs monsieur le
ministre pourquoi avoir choisi ce titre
pleine emploi vous mentionnez certes
avec timidité les travailleurs
handicapés les professionnels de la
petite enfance mais où sont passés les
jeunes où sont passés les seniors les
avez-vous relégués aux oubliés de notre
société sont-ils à vos yeux des acteurs
sans valeur sur le marché du travail
après la tempête que fut la réforme des
retraites on s'entend on s'attendait à
avoir émergé des solutions pour que ceux
que vous poussez à travailler davantage
puisse enfin le faire au mettre de le
faire relève soit d'incompétence soit
d'une flagrante indifférence je vous
remercie
monsieur
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre passez sous la barre des 5% de
chômage en France et ceux avant la fin
du quinquennat en 2027 a été évidemment
un objectif louable mais un objectif
jugé inatteignable par de nombreux
économistes de nombreux points de
frictions ont déjà été identifiés
notamment la transformation de Pôle
emploi en France travaille vous annoncez
la création de ce réseau qui permettrait
d'avoir la même procédure d'entrée pour
toutes les personnes en recherche
d'emploi ou rencontrant des difficultés
d'insertion et ce quel que soit la porte
à laquelle elle frappe Pôle Emploi Cap
Emploi mission locale vous prévoyez de
rebaptiser Pôle emploi avec le même nom
que celui du réseau France travail qui
deviendrait d'institution phare de cette
transformation de la politique
mais c'est une source de confusion
supplémentaire ces changements lexicaux
sont parfaitement dérisoires et vont
troubler davantage une population déjà
fragile croyez-vous réellement changer
ou améliorer les chiffres au-delà de ces
révolutions sémantiques la réalité de
nombreux territoires comme le mien c'est
un chômage endémique il y a une
désindustrialisation et des
délocalisations désastreuses imposées
par votre idéologie mondialiste
9,2 % de chômeurs dans mon département
monsieur le ministre 9% de chômeurs
alors pour cette France qui souffre
monsieur le ministre que prévoyez vous
de faire concrètement pour enfin changer
la situation
merci Monsieur neuder merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur Miss mes chers
collègues nous reprenons donc cette
session parlementaire par cet examen du
plein d'emploi moi je pense que
effectivement le plein emploi et
l'emploi et la première les protections
sociales puisque c'est source
d'insertion et d'inclusion et je crois
qu'on s'y trompe pas les Français
préfèrent vivre du fruit de leur travail
plutôt que de vivre des allocations de
quelle qu'elle soit et je pense qu'il
est important justement de de remettre
ces notions de mérite pour récompenser
ceux qui se lèvent tôt et qui vont
travailler et qui est cette différence
de gradient entre les revenus de la
location sociale et les revenus du
travail c'est étonnant de voir quand
même que 40% des allocataires ne sont
pas inscrits à Pôle emploi et donc ne
sont pas en recherche d'emploi il est
donc important au cours de ce projet de
loi de prévoir de rappeler les droits et
les devoirs par cette contrat
d'engagement de 15 heures minimale qui
peut être fait sur de la formation sur
de l'activité ou d'autres activités au
sein associations de collectivités
locales je rappelle ici que c'est des
mesures de réciprocité qui ont été déjà
développées dans beaucoup de
départements en Isère nous le faisons
depuis 2016 avec beaucoup de
satisfaction de l'ensemble des acteurs
que ça soit les syndicaux ou les acteurs
de du social attention cependant sur un
deuxième point de ne pas recentraliser
l'ensemble de vos dispositifs en tant
qu'élus régional j'ai pu entendre les
revendications de région de France qui
restent les régions restent
l'organisateur de la formation de
l'orientation dans le titre de leurs
compétences et qui pour l'instant n'ont
pas beaucoup de nouvelles sur les plans
d'investissement dans les compétences
les fameux pics qui vont effectivement
se terminer en décembre 2023 et pour
lequel nous n'avons pas de retour et
pour ce que lequel tout cela n'est pas
dans la continuité de la loi 3DS qui
était plutôt en faveur d'une
décentralisation enfin vous savez déjà
été dit cette réforme a un coup plus de
3 milliards d'euros en faisant un peu la
poche de lunédique via les cotisations
les travailleurs et des entreprises
attention quand même au coût de cette
réforme maintenant le le mot Pôle emploi
qui est bien identifié qui fera une
économie de 500 millions d'euros et puis
comme l'a dit Philippe Juvin vous l'avez
compris notre groupe restera à l'écoute
avec deux fils rouges le maintien des 15
heures d'activité et la façon de
recentralisation
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre merci pour les réponses
précises que vous apportez depuis le
début de l'examen de ce texte ma
question porte sur les personnes les
plus éloignées de l'emploi en effet les
difficultés à s'insérer sur le marché du
travail son nombreuses et variées le
manque d'expérience professionnelle les
compétences obsolètes les problèmes de
santé les problèmes de garde d'enfant
mais aussi les problèmes de mobilité
habiter loin d'une activité économique
c'est sûr que ça complique la
possibilité de travailler mais cela
complique aussi la possibilité de se
former dans ce texte est prévu un
meilleur accompagnement personnalisé
mais pouvez-vous nous dire comment vous
voyez l'évolution de la formation et
notamment de la formation à distance
pour permettre aux personnes qui ont des
difficultés de mobilité de pouvoir elles
aussi se former merci
merci Madame Corneloup
merci Madame ma présidente monsieur
ministre vous évoquiez précédemment la
problématique des mères isolés et des
personnes porteuses de handicap qui sont
des catégories particulièrement
concernées par l'éloignement de l'emploi
et vous disiez qu'il faudrait peut-être
adapter voir déroger
je pense que si les freins au retour à
l'emploi tel que la garde d'enfants la
mobilité est bien d'autres sont
identifiées il m'apparaît essentiel à
l'heure où nous cherchons à construire
une société toujours plus inclusive de
ne pas stigmatiser ces catégories mais
au contraire de prévoir un
accompagnement plus intensif renforcé le
risque serait d'écarter ces personnes du
dispositif au contraire les intégrer
pleinement en prévoyant des mesures
fortes d'accompagnement pour lever les
freins avec comme objectif premier de
leur permettre une première expérience
dans le monde du travail mais également
dans le monde associatif en accentuant
la coopération entre acteurs
doit être une véritable opportunité pour
ceux qui sont très éloignés de l'emploi
vertueuse pour la personne mais
également pour l'entreprise puisque nous
le savons seul l'employeur de 20
salariés plus est tenues d'employés des
bénéficiaires de l'obligation des
travailleurs handicapés dans la
proportion minimale de 6% et nous
connaissons également les réticences de
certains employeurs à embaucher des
personnes handicapées par ailleurs ce
texte n'évoque pas les limites du cumul
entre RSA et prestations sociales qui
peuvent être de véritables
désincitations retour à l'emploi et qui
constitue donc un frein ou pleine emploi
pourquoi ne pas avoir prévu par exemple
un plafonnement à 75% du SMIC dans les
cas de cumul prestations sociales et RSA
je vous remercie
merci Monsieur Monet
merci madame la Présidente
sur ce texte monsieur le ministre ce que
nous contestons c'est bien votre
conception de la valeur du travail et
c'est je pense d'ailleurs vous parler
d'emploi non on vous parle de travail
c'est bien là-dessus qu'il y a
divergence puisque pour vous le travail
n'est plus considéré comme une source
d'épanouissement et d'émancipation mais
quand ma besoin économique à remplir à
aucun moment vous ne questionnez la
nature des emplois tout à l'heure vous
nous dites
tout à l'heure vous nous dites l'emploi
va mieux parce qu'il y a plus de CDI
dois-je vous rappeler qu'il y a des CD à
temps partiel contraint et dois-je vous
rappeler aussi qu'aujourd'hui une étude
qui vient de montrer que 44% des
salariés sont en détresse psychologique
par contre vous concluez que les privés
d'emploi sont des fainéants excusez-moi
l'expression
madame la Présidente fait respecter le
silence parce que c'est difficile
d'intervenir
vous conclus ils sont défiants parce
qu'il faut les contraintes réactivité je
sais pas si vous avez déjà c'est de la
contrainte puisqu'il y a sanction je
sais pas si vous avez déjà accompagné
des gens privés d'emploi mais en
accompagne pas des gens par la
contrainte et d'ailleurs je regrette que
ces 15 ans d'activité qui ont été
expérimentés n'est pas fait l'objet
d'une évaluation et de voir comment ça
s'est passé on a aucun élément sur ces
15 heures peut-être qu'ils ont été mis
en place dans les dans les départements
on sent bien que c'est des objectifs de
chiffres mais pas d'accompagnement que
vous mais vous mettez en place
d'ailleurs vous ignorez les nouvelles
aspirations de au travail notamment chez
les jeunes depuis le covid qui ont une
autre conception du travail
et deux dernières remarques
quand vous dites qu'il y a des
employeurs qui cherchent des salariés
qui n'arrive pas à recruter j'ai été
coupé tout à l'heure il y a pas j'ai pas
de compteur en plus je suis désolé j'ai
fini oui oui on reçoit des employeurs
qui cherchent des employés dans nos
permanences morceaux aussi des
demandeurs d'emploi aujourd'hui il y a
300 sens 7000 emplois disponibles pour 3
millions de chômeurs donc le compte n'y
est pas donc comment imaginer réduire le
chômage et enrayer le chômage sans une
vraie politique de création d'emplois
madame au temps
on y arrive madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre
forcer les allocataires du RSA à
travailler c'est un recul social
impressionnant alors on vous connaissait
monsieur le ministre on connaît votre
gouvernement après ce que vous avez été
capable de faire sur les retraites mais
là je crois que vous partez d'un
postulat qui est particulièrement
erroné particulièrement faux parce que
dans votre tête au fond le chômage ce
n'est pas la faute d'emploi créé
satisfaisant c'est de la faute des
feignants qui ne veulent pas travailler
et c'est toute la logique qui sous-tend
la proposition de loi que vous nous
proposez aujourd'hui en réalité si en
réalité il y a moins d'emplois que de
chômeurs et le rapport est de 1 à 6 donc
la question n'est pas de forcer des
chômeurs à travailler mais d'essayer de
créer des emplois de qualité et de
partager le temps de travail et s'il
existe des chefs d'entreprise qui
effectivement ont du mal à recruter
personne ne ni cela c'est d'abord parce
que les emplois sont mal payés au regard
de leur pénibilité et puis qu'il y a de
plus en plus de personnes qui
s'interrogent sur le sens du travail et
c'est aussi que notre société dans notre
société des personnes se retrouvent en
situation de vulnérabilité situation de
villemurabilité de difficultés sociales
en chaîne qui rendent l'insertion très
difficile et qui aussi ont des
répercussions sur le plan psychologique
donc vous avez des gens qui se
retrouvent brisés fracassées par des
conditions sociales extrêmement dures et
par aussi le fait de ne pas avoir
d'emploi dans la durée et donc si un
minimum pour vivre leur a été donné
c'est précisément par cet effort de
solidarité qui est indispensable dans
une société qui respecte les principes
républicains je rappelle que le RSA pour
une personne seule c'est 607 euros et
que le seuil de pauvreté il est à 1102
euros donc ce sont des gens qui vivent
en dessous du seuil de pauvreté et que
la Constitution dit que le travail est
un droit et pas un devoir alors ma
question monsieur le ministre très
brièvement très vite le salaire minimum
aujourd'hui en France il y a 11 euros 52
la durée minimale du temps de travail
partiel c'est 24 heures par semaine si
vous conditionnez le RSA à 15 heures
voilà
[Musique]
16 secondes pour poser votre question
vous la posez pas donc à un moment faut
arrêter
ça fait 7 € de l'heure comment vous
faites la merde merci et maintenant je
passe la parole à Monsieur le Ministre
que les réponses sont attendues merci
madame la Présidente je vais essayer de
répondre aux nombreuses questions pardon
si le s'il est un peu télégraphique vu
le nombre d'entre elles parfois
concentré sur le même intervenant
d'abord pour dire que pour ce qui
concerne le retour à l'emploi ça a été
évoqué par Monsieur Bazin en première
intervention mais aussi par Monsieur
notaire je partage mille fois le fait
que le retour à l'emploi doit être
valorisé j'ai dit tout à l'heure il a
parfois des moments pendant lesquels le
retour à l'emploi n'est pas ce n'est pas
suffisamment valorisé parce que les
aides des salariés modestes sont plus
longs à se mettre en place que la perte
des droits de d'allocataires de minima
sociaux et donc c'est sur cette période
de transition qu'il faut que nous
puissions travailler disposons
aujourd'hui d'un modèle logiciel qui
s'appelle Estime et qui permet de
calculer cela et qui montre que la
reprise d'activité et une reprise
gagnant-gagnant mais avec parfois un
décalage dans le temps et c'est ce
décalage dans le temps qu'il faut
pouvoir compenser deuxième question qui
était posée c'était la partie pression
des communes et des EPCI oui à tous les
niveaux avec une voix délibérative donc
au niveau local au niveau des parcs
mentales régionales et nationales ce qui
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui et nous
souhaitons que les élus puissent accéder
aux informations de la plateforme dit
horizontale dans les règles évidemment
du rgpd et les préconisations de la CNIL
d'où le renvoie un certain nombre de
décrets je ne reviens pas sur l'article
10 vous le savez c'est un article posé
pas porté par ma collègue renverger mais
qui aura l'occasion de venir en débattre
avec vous
sur le niveau le plus pertinent pour
assurer la présidence nous considérons
la coprésidence nous considérons
qu'évidemment c'est la région au niveau
régional et le département au niveau
départemental mais je reste convaincu
que c'est
je reste convaincu que c'est aux élus de
chacun des comités de désigner qui est
le meilleur président lorsque le bassin
d'emploi correspond strictement à
l'intercommunalité il y a évidemment une
logique territoriale qui pousse vers
l'intercommunalité mais ne présente pas
ces débats par contre je souhaite que
nous puissions revenir dans les débats
sur les modalités désignation et il me
semblerait utile que ce soit les
associations de mer à l'échelle de
chaque département qui soit chargé
d'organiser la désignation comme elles
savent le faire dans des commissions par
exemple sur la de terre la désignation
des maires et des présidents de PCI si
les gens dans les comités départementaux
et infra départementaux sur les
questions posées par Monsieur Viry je
sais qu'il a eu quelques irrecevabilités
je me prononce pas de suivi je pense que
les débats que nous avons autour du
pdfss peut apporter des réponses sur la
question du travail indépendant de la
même manière nous avons fait un choix
qui est de confier aux partenaires
sociaux la discussion d'un heili sur
l'emploi des seniors c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous n'avons pas inscrit
de disposition sur l'emploi des seniors
mais nous nous sommes engagés à
transposer de manière fidèle et
intégrale comme nous l'avons fait sur
partage de la valeur l'éventuelle accord
qu'il signerait sur l'emploi des seniors
je ne partage pas la crainte de Monsieur
viric quand il dit que le moins
insertion n'apparaît pas je n'ai pas
compté combien de fois il apparaît mais
à de nombreuses reprises et surtout les
structures d'insertion par l'activité
économique seront membres des comités ce
qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui ce qui
leur permettra aussi de participer à
l'écriture de la feuille de route qui
les concerne au premier chef sur la
question du baluchonnage de Madame Vidal
la possibilité sera donnée dans la pelle
bien vieillir de revenir sur ses
dispositions ça sera porté par ma
collègues en revergers Fadila katabi sur
la question les questions qui ont suivi
de Monsieur aviranier monsieur Boyard
monsieur Fernandez ou monsieur cloué qui
portait sur la philosophie même du
dispositif en 88 quand le RMI est créé
le i c'est l'insertion il y a un contrat
d'engagement réciproque il y a une
possibilité de sanction et il y a une
volonté d'assurer un minimum
préparer ça et retrouver une activité
dans les meilleures conditions possibles
il y a je tiens le préciser notamment en
réponse à Monsieur Boyard il n'y a
aucune expérimentation des sanctions et
la suspension dans le cadre des 18
expérimentations tout simplement parce
que la sanction de suspension n'existe
pas dans la loi et que les
expérimentations se mènent à droite
constant et pour préciser mon propos il
est hors de question au contraire qui
est plus fragiles ceux qui peut-être
devraient relever d'une allocation qui
n'est pas une allocation de retour
relativité en soi privée et dans la loi
vous verrez en la lisant que il y a des
dispositions qui permettent justement de
prévoir que ces personnes là les plus
fragiles puissent être accompagnés
socialement sans perspective immédiate
d'insertion professionnelle parce que
nous savons justement leurs difficultés
c'est écrit en toute lettre et c'est
aussi pour ça qu'à l'article 6 nous
reconnaissons le rôle des associations
pour aller chercher les plus fragiles
qu'on appelle parfois les invisibles et
donc il n'y a aucun risque de sortie la
réflexion que j'ai eue et que j'ai faite
en équat à Monsieur Daredevil c'est une
réflexion à beaucoup plus long terme
parce qu'un jour et je l'espère nous
serons pleins d'emploi et peut-être que
nous regarder en face des hommes et des
femmes qui n'ont pas la capacité de
retourner sur le marché de l'emploi et
voir comment les accompagner
différemment qu'est-ce que nous faisons
aujourd'hui avec le RSA y compris pour
sortir de l'hypocrisie d'un retour à
l'activité qui ne serait pas possible et
je souhaite évidemment qu'il y a le
moins possible que et que le plus le
plus grand nombre possible puisse être
en capacité s'ils sont bien accompagnés
de revenir à l'emploi sur les questions
évoquées par Monsieur Catteau au-delà de
quelques accusations qui la portait à
l'encontre du projet de loi les aidants
et les familles monoparentales sont
prises en compte justement pour faire
l'objet d'un suivi particulier et adapté
et c'est une des avancées du texte du
Sénat que dont nous félicitons et qui
nous vous proposerons de garder sur
les questions relatives les questions de
Monsieur Nader je le répète monsieur le
député pas de recentralisation vraiment
pas je n'aurai pas sur les questions de
compétences mais vraiment l'association
et la participation avec voie des
libérative au comité d'orientation
permettra aux collectivités de décider
avec les autres d'orientation
qu'aujourd'hui elle ne connaissent pas
notamment sur les orientations du
service public de l'emploi au sens
service public national j'ai vu quelques
inquiétudes de l'ARF et je sais et vous
m'avez dit elles sont les régions sont
en attente sur deux aspects d'abord la
mise en place de France travail je tiens
à préciser que en métropole sur les 13
régions cette ont déjà signé un
protocole de préfiguration de France
travail avec le gouvernement et sous et
avec Pôle Emploi donc les choses
avancent plutôt bien avec les présidents
de région quel que soit d'ailleurs leurs
orientations politiques sur le pic c'est
cette semaine que je dois rencontrer
François Bono pour voir avec lui la
trajectoire budgétaire que nous allons
leur proposer en leur donnant une
souplesse en du notamment en revenant
sur le principe du socle qui était
extrêmement rigide pour certaines
régions et en permettant d'adapter
région Paris Région la répartition l'axe
entre l'axe 1 et l'axe 2 sur les
formations qualifiantes et sur les
préparations à l'emploi ça fait partie
des différents sujets sur lesquels nous
allons pouvoir avancer dans les jours
qui viennent madame rise m'a interrogé
sur la formation ouverte à distance et
donc sur la formation à distance c'est
un vrai sujet que j'aurais dû évoquer
tout à l'heure aujourd'hui
pas à mise en place une offre de
formation intégralement à distance et
qui permet à des demandeurs d'emploi qui
ont des normes problèmes de mobilité de
suivre des formations qualifiantes
totalement à distance c'est une
compétence qui normalement relève plutôt
des régions au titre de la formation des
demandeurs d'emploi très peu de régions
la mettent en œuvre nous avons proposé
dans le texte de dispositions qui
permettent de sécuriser la mise en
oeuvre de ce programme de formation
ouverte à distance pour Pôle emploi sans
privé les régions du droit de le faire
bien évidemment ce que je vous
proposerai dans les débats c'est que
nous puissions rétablir cette
disposition qui a été supprimée au Sénat
tout en précisant que ça sera fait dans
le cas d'un accord et d'une convention
de réciprocité avec les régions de
manière à ce que là où les régions
souhaitent intervenir elles puissent le
faire en parfaite complémentarité avec
Pôle emploi mais ce sont des modules qui
fonctionnent bien qui nous faut garder
et qui sont des réponses à parfois des
demandeurs d'emploi en situation de
monoparentalité d'éloignement
géographique de problèmes de mobilité et
auquel on peut donner donner ses
réponses là
sur les questions de famille
monoparentale et des dons évoqués par
Madame cornelot comme je disais les
dispositions adoptées par le Sénat ont
permis de compléter le texte et de bien
dire qu'il faut faire attention à leur
situation réelle je vous rejoins quand
vous dites finalement les difficultés
sont-elles sont elles qui font encore
plus intensifiées et je pense qu'il faut
faire les deux ça veut dire que
lorsqu'il y a des problèmes de mobilité
de garde d'enfant insurmontable il faut
évidemment dispenser des 15 à 20h quand
ça n'est pas réalisable mais lorsque
c'est possible il faut évidemment de te
mettre encore plus de moyens pour
permettre l'insertion professionnelle et
la sortie de la précarité qui qui sont
connus et donc la personnalisation des
parcours répond je crois totalement à ça
pour le reste que vous avez évoqué
notamment sur le handicap je partage
totalement et la seule disposition sur
laquelle nous vous proposons de revenir
madame Le Neubourg l'a évoqué c'est une
disposition minorant la participation
des entreprises qui en réalité aurait un
drôle d'effet d'aubaine puisque les
entreprises les moins vertueuses
pourraient bénéficier d'une fois de
l'aide d'une fois de l'amélioration ce
qui n'est pas tout à fait l'objectif
poursuivi mais le débat permettra d'y
revenir
sur
la capacité de notre économie à créer de
l'emploi que Monsieur Monet évoqué je
crois que les chiffres et la création de
2 millions d'emplois parlent pour
eux-mêmes il viendrait débat sur le
temps partiel subi et dans le cadre de
la conférence sociale que j'ai évoquée
ça fait partie des items que nous aurons
l'occasion de regarder et enfin la Motin
a conclu sur le niveau du RSA avec
raison puisque c'est 607 euros pour une
personne seule c'est la démonstration se
chiffre là que nous ne sommes vraiment
pas quitte de notre devoir de solidarité
quand on a versé 607 euros à quelqu'un
c'est un minimum de subsistance et que
tu dois tout doit être mise en oeuvre
pour permettre aux allocataires d'en
sortir et d'aller vers l'emploi et un
emploi le mieux rémunéré et de la
meilleure qualité possible merci à
toutes et à tous